This special episode of Office Ladies is brought to you by Hershey's Kisses. So earlier this year, we recorded our first ever live Office Ladies episode. People flew in from all over. It was so crazy. It was so funny. This is some of our like OG Office Ladies fans that have been with us from the very beginning. We got to meet so many of you. It was absolutely a blast.
本期特别版《办公室女孩》由好时之吻（Hershey's Kisses）倾情赞助。今年早些时候，我们录制了史上第一期《办公室女孩》现场版播客。大家从四面八方赶来，真是太疯狂了，太有趣了。这些都是从一开始就陪伴我们的老粉。我们见到了你们中的很多人，这绝对是一段无比欢乐的时光。
And we couldn't be happier to partner with Hers her shoes to now bring it to you all to listen. This collaboration is kind of perfect because later on in the episode, we are going to talk about kisses. Yeah. That's right. We dive back into the debate about a certain first kiss on the office. But first, let's talk about a different kind of kiss. Well, you know, the holidays are a time to break out your best outfits. And when it comes to candy, I'm sorry, but is there a better dress treat than a Hershey's kiss with its sparkling festive foils? This holiday season, you and your family will delight in decorating the house with kisses
我们非常高兴能与好时之吻合作，现在把这期节目带给大家收听。这次合作简直天衣无缝，因为在节目的后面，我们将聊聊“吻”这个话题。没错，我们再次深入探讨了关于《办公室》中某个初吻的争论。但首先，我们来聊聊另一种“吻”。你知道的，节日就是展现你最好着装的时候。说到糖果，抱歉，难道还有比带着闪亮节日锡纸的好时之吻更好看的节日甜点吗？这个节日季，你和家人一定会喜欢用包装在闪亮红、绿、银色锡纸里的
chocolates dressed in shining red, green silver foils. Their snowman foils are even Santa hats. The Santa hats are so cute. My mom stole my bag of Santa hat. She did. She did. Story for later. Hershey's Heartwarming the World.
之吻巧克力来装扮家园。它们的雪人锡纸甚至还有圣诞老人帽。圣诞老人帽太可爱了。我妈偷了我的一袋圣诞老人帽。她真的偷了。她真的偷了。这事以后再说。好时，温暖世界。
Learn more at www.hercyland.com. All right. Are you guys ready? Yeah. OK. Sam, can we get a theme song? Here we go. I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you.
了解更多请访问 www.hersheyland.com。好了，大家准备好了吗？准备好了。好的，萨姆，能来段主题曲吗？我们开始吧。我是珍妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the Offs ladies. Hi guys! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness!
每周我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女孩。大家好！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！
Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness!
我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！
Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness! Oh my goodness. Oh my God. Thank you all for being here. We know a lot of you traveled to be here. We cannot tell you how much we appreciate it. This is tears here in the first row.
我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪。天哪。谢谢大家来到这里。我们知道你们很多人都是特意赶来这里的。我们无法表达我们有多感激。第一排都有人感动得落泪了。
Tears. We have some tears. Now you're going to make us cry. Yeah, no, yeah. Wait. We don't have tissues. We don't have tissues. That's the one thing we didn't think of, and so this is our very first time recording a podcast in front
眼泪。我们看到有人落泪了。现在你们要把我们弄哭了。对，不，对。等等。我们没有纸巾。我们没有纸巾。这是我们唯一没想到的一点，所以这是我们第一次在
of a live audience. Yeah. So amazing. Yeah. So it might be, it might be slunky, but we'll get through it. But just seeing your faces here is just making my heart beat so fast. This is so special.
现场观众面前录制播客。是的。太棒了。是的。所以过程可能、可能会有点磕磕绊绊，但我们会挺过去的。不过看到你们的面孔，我的心跳得好快。这太特别了。
You know I have to document it for office ladies. Oh, OK. OK. OK. OK. Are you ready? You, oh, you guys. OK.
你知道我得为《办公室女孩》记录下来。哦，好的。好的。好的。好的。准备好了吗？你们，哦，天哪。好的。
Will you guys say hi? So today we are going to do our male bag fan appreciation episode. That is why you're here. Yes Yes You know so many of you have written in over the years and have just shared your stories with us. I'm so emotional. And we just thought it would be really fun to open up our off-sledish mailbag with you all.
大家能打个招呼吗？所以今天我们要录制的是男性听众邮件/粉丝答谢特辑。这就是你们来到这里的目的。没错，没错。你知道的，这些年来你们有那么多人写信来，跟我们分享你们的故事。我太激动了。我们觉得和大家一起打开我们的“办公室女孩”邮件箱会非常有趣。
And we're just so happy you're here. Yes, but first, we want to introduce you to our team. Yes, our off-sledish. All right, so first of all, our senior producer, Cassie Jerkins. Cassie! Whoo! No!
我们太高兴你们能来了。是的，但首先，我们要向大家介绍我们的团队。是的，我们的“办公室女孩”团队。好的，首先，我们的资深制片人，卡西·杰金斯。卡西！呜呼！不！
Whoo! And we also have our editing and mixing engineer, Jordan Duffy. Jordan! Yay! Our in-studio engineer, Sam Keeper! Sam! And our associate producer, Ainsley Babako. And we also have Colin and Cody there around the corner somewhere.
呜呼！我们还有剪辑和混音师，乔丹·达菲。乔丹！耶！我们的驻场录音师，萨姆·基弗！萨姆！我们的助理制片人，艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们还有科林和科迪，他们就在某个拐角处。
We have a reception little party planned for after, so you'll get to meet everyone. Everyone that helps us make this show means so much to us. Our merchandise team, Ilyana, who does our website. Everyone here at Syrias XM that helped make this happen today. So we thought we would kick things off with a piece of mail about our team, a particular team member. I've gotten a lot of these letters. You got a fan mail flurry about it. I got a fan mail flurry about it. This one is from Marney W from Dallas Baby. Is that what she wrote? That was she wrote. Dallas Baby?
我们为结束后策划了一个小型招待会，所以你们有机会见到每个人。每一个帮助我们制作这个节目的人对我们都意义重大。我们的周边团队，伊利亚娜，她负责我们的网站。今天在天狼星XM广播帮助实现这一切的每一个人。所以我们想以一封关于我们团队、关于某个特定团队成员的信件来拉开序幕。我收到过很多这样的信。你收到了一阵粉丝来信轰炸。我收到了一阵粉丝来信轰炸。这封信来自达拉斯的玛尼·W，宝贝。她是这么写的吗？这就是她写的。达拉斯宝贝？
Yes. Yes. Marney said, hi, in the last episode I listened to, you said our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco rather than Ainsley Bubbaco, as you have been pronouncing it in all of the previous episodes. Oh, Marney got ya. Did Ainsley let you know you've been saying her name?
是的。是的。玛尼说，嗨，在我听的上一期节目中，你们说我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布巴科（Ainsley Bubbaco），而不是你们在之前所有节目中一直发音的艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Babako）。哦，玛尼抓到你们了。艾恩斯利有提醒过你们名字的发音吗？
I've been intrigued by her name ever since I first heard it on your show and I want to know all about this, please. Marney, I'm going to tell you. Yeah. I have known Ainsley for going on 10 years. We had the same acting coach when I was working on my book, The Actors Life. She was one of my readers.
自从我第一次在你们节目中听到她的名字起，我就对它很感兴趣，我想了解关于这个名字的一切，求科普。玛尼，我来告诉你。是的。我和艾恩斯利认识快10年了。当我创作我的书《演员的生活》时，我们有同一个表演教练。她是我的读者之一。
She did the transcriptions for me. We've been friends a long time. She joined the office ladies team and is still doing our transcriptions. She helps us with our outlines. Okay, here's the thing. In all of these years of knowing her, I never had a reason to say her last name to her face.
她为我做文字记录。我们是很长时间的朋友了。她加入了《办公室女孩》团队，现在还在做我们的文字记录。她帮我们整理大纲。好吧，事情是这样的。在认识她的这么多年里，我从来没有理由当面说出她的姓氏。
What? Because listen, this is a southern thing. Like, my mom's friend is Sudan. Her last name is Dean. We all say Sudan. That's her name, Sudan. But you don't go around saying, hi, Angela Kinsey. I don't.
什么？因为听着，这是南方人的习惯。就像我妈妈的朋友苏丹（Sudan）。她的姓是迪恩（Dean）。我们都叫她苏丹。那是她的名字，苏丹。但你不会到处说，嗨，安吉拉·金西。我不会。
Hi, Jennifer. Hi, Sam Keifer. Hi. Never had occasion to do this until we are at a party I don't go around saying hi, Angela Kinsey. I don't. Hi, Jennifer. Hi, Sam Keifer. Hi. Never had occasion to do this. Until we are at a party celebrating our 100th episode of the office ladies. Yes.
嗨，珍妮弗。嗨，萨姆·基弗。嗨。从来没有机会这样做，直到我们在一个派对上——我不会到处说嗨，安吉拉·金西。我不会。嗨，珍妮弗。嗨，萨姆·基弗。嗨。从来没有机会这样做。直到我们在一个庆祝《办公室女孩》播出100集的派对上。是的。
Woo! We threw a fun dinner party because we love a party. And Jenna and I thought we would get up and think our team. And that's when Ainsley was like, by the way, you've been saying my last name wrong for a lot of episodes. I was like Ainsley, you've been listening to them. You've been transcribing them.
呜呼！我们举办了一个有趣的晚宴，因为我们喜欢聚会。珍娜和我觉得我们可以起立感谢我们的团队。就在那时，艾恩斯利说，顺便说一句，你们很多期节目都把我的姓氏读错了。我说，艾恩斯利，你一直在听这些节目。你一直在做文字记录。
Ainsley come here. Why? Why did you wait so long to tell us? A couple of reasons. One, I'm very polite. Why did you wait so long to tell us? A couple of reasons. One, I'm very polite. Two, I knew that I had never said my last name to you, so you didn't know any better.
艾恩斯利，过来。为什么？你为什么等了这么久才告诉我们？原因有几个。第一，我非常有礼貌。你为什么等了这么久才告诉我们？原因有几个。第一，我非常有礼貌。第二，我知道我从来没有对你们说过我的姓氏，所以你们不知道也正常。
And three, the show is, you know, a train that is left this station. It's already documented. So I just thought, why mess up a good thing? Well, I'm very happy we are now pronouncing your last name correctly. It's documented. So I just thought, why mess up a good thing? Well, I'm very happy we are now pronouncing your last name correctly. It is actually Bibico. No, come on.
第三，这个节目嘛，你知道的，就像一列已经开出车站的火车。它已经被记录下来了。所以我当时想，何必去破坏一个好好的局面呢？好吧，我很高兴我们现在能正确读出你的姓氏了。它已经被记录下来了。所以我当时想，何必去破坏一个好好的局面呢？好吧，我很高兴我们现在能正确读出你的姓氏了。其实是“比比科”（Bibico）。不，拜托。
No. Yeah, you know what? We're going to open up a lot of mail with you guys. Woo! Woo! Woo! I want to start off with something that I know you're gonna love, Angela. Okay. This is a letter from Jovi and Oregon who did an in-depth breakdown of what it costs Jim
不。是的，你知道吗？我们要和你们一起拆很多信。呜呼！呜呼！呜呼！我想从一个我知道你会喜欢的东西开始，安吉拉。好的。这是一封来自俄勒冈州的乔维的信，他深入分析了吉姆捉弄德怀特所花费的成本。
to prank Dwight. Oh, yes! Oh, the entire series. Yes, I've always saying this. Like, how does he have the time? How does he have the money? These are big pranks. Okay, he does not break down the time.
哦，是的！哦，整个系列。是的，我一直都在说这个。比如，他哪来的时间？他哪来的资金？这些都是大捉弄。好吧，他没有分析时间。
Okay. He does break down the actual cost, but he made a few caveats. So I'm going to tell you, first, he only tallied the cost of Jim's pranks played on Dwight. Oh. He does not include any pranks on Michael, Andy, Pam, Karen, Todd Packer, Gabe, anybody.
好吧。他确实分析了实际成本，但他做了一些前提说明。所以我来告诉你，首先，他只统计了吉姆对德怀特恶作剧的成本。哦。他没有把针对迈克尔、安迪、帕姆、凯伦、托德·帕克、盖布或任何其他人的恶作剧计算在内。
Okay, just Dwight. Mm-hmm. Okay. He also did not factor in white. Mm-hmm. Okay. He also did not factor in any loss of sales commissions. Oh. Due to the time spent on pranking. Yes. Okay.
好吧，只有德怀特。嗯哼。好吧。他也没有将销售佣金的损失计算在内。哦。因为恶作剧花费的时间。是的。好吧。
And he did not consider any cost that would be part of office supplies or office expenses. Right. So, for example, in season one, when he sets up all the pencils, Right. Pencils were free. OK. He just rated the supply cabinet. Yeah.
他也没有考虑任何属于办公用品或办公开销的成本。对。所以，举个例子，在第一季中，当他把所有的铅笔都摆好时，对。铅笔是免费的。好的。他只是洗劫了办公用品柜。是的。
He also did not include Jim's Gutenpronks during Dwight's Best Disment Festival in the finale. OK. OK. All right. Finally, his prices are based on 2023 dollar value. OK. He did not go through and figure out the dollar value in 2005, 2000.
大结局中德怀特的最佳制服节期间，吉姆的古腾恶作剧也没有计算在内。好的。好的。好吧。最后，他的价格是基于2023年的美元价值计算的。好的。他并没有去计算2005年、2000年的实际美元价值。
Joe, it's okay. Okay. So then what he did was he broke it down season by season. He listed every single prank, it's approximate cost, and then a total for that season. I want to say, I was shocked at the number of pranks that cost zero dollars. Like which ones? Like the pencil one I told you about.
乔，没关系。好吧。所以他做的是按季节进行拆解。他列出了每一个恶作剧、它的近似成本，然后是那一季的总费用。我想说，我对零美元恶作剧的数量感到震惊。比如哪些？就像我刚才告诉你的铅笔那个。
Oh, because of the supply cabinet. Yes. For example, in all of season one, the total amount of money spent was only one dollar and 39 cents. Come on. And that was for the box of Jello that he put his stapler in. Okay. Every other prank from season one was using found objects and office supplies. So maybe I didn't have to be so grumpy at Jim. Maybe he's not blowing his salary on pranks. Well, I don't know.
哦，因为用了办公用品柜。是的。例如，在整个第一季中，花掉的总金额只有1.39美元。拜托。那是用来买果冻的盒子的钱，他把订书机放进去了。好的。第一季中的所有其他恶作剧都是用现成的物品和办公用品完成的。所以也许我没必要对吉姆那么生气的。也许他并没有把薪水挥霍在恶作剧上。好吧，我不知道。
You tell me, in the end, over all nine seasons, he spent $1,889 in $11 cents on pranks. That's ridiculous. spent $1,889.11 on pranks. That's ridiculous. That's ridiculous. What happened to like, like just like silly string? Well, that would have cost probably what? A $1.50. I guess it adds up. It does. It adds up.
你告诉我，最后，在所有九个季节里，他在恶作剧上总共花费了1,889美元11美分。太荒谬了。在恶作剧上花费了1,889.11美元。太荒谬了。太荒谬了。那些比如，比如彩带之类的东西去哪了？那可能得花多少钱？1.50美元。我猜积少成多吧。确实。积少成多。
Pranking adds up. That's right. It's the moral to this story. That's what it says. The most expensive pranking season is season 8. In that season, Jim spent $634.25. Wow. Do you want to know what the single most expensive prank was?
恶作剧成本会累积。没错。这就是这个故事的寓意。信上是这么说的。最昂贵的恶作剧季是第八季。在那一季中，吉姆花掉了634.25美元。哇。你想知道单笔最昂贵的恶作剧是什么吗？
Can you guess? Is it in season eight? It's not. It's in season three. Is it all the gift wrapping when he gift wrapped the whole... When he made the fakie desk? No, I'll give you a hint The single most expensive prank was in season three
你猜得到吗？是在第八季吗？不是。是在第三季。是所有那些礼品包装吗，当他把整个……当他做一个假办公桌的时候？不，我给你个提示，单笔最昂贵的恶作剧在第三季
Mm-hmm. Can you guess anybody out here have a guess? Nope, it was not the power line It was when he shipped Dwight's desk to Roswell, New Mexico. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. He says this was a deleted scene, but the cost of that prank would have been $500. Way to go, Joe. That is like amazing. Yes.
嗯哼。你们有谁能猜到吗？不，不是高压线。是当他把德怀特的办公桌寄到新墨西哥州罗斯韦尔的时候。我的天哪。我的天哪。他说这是一场被删减的戏，但那个恶作剧的成本将是500美元。干得漂亮，乔。这太惊人了。是的。
And the second most expensive was in season eight in free family portrait studio. He estimates that when he switched white suit with a tear-away Velcro suit, he thinks that cost about $310 because he had to buy a suit. He had to have a tailor sew Velcro into it and he had to tip the dry cleaner.
第二贵的是第八季的免费家庭肖像摄影棚。他估计，当吉姆把德怀特的西装换成带有魔术贴的撕裂装时，他认为这大约花了310美元，因为他不得不买一套西装。他得让裁缝把魔术贴缝进去，还得给干洗店小费。
So there you go. Now, if anyone would like to do a breakdown of the amount of time Jim has spent on a prank, I would love to read it. Joe, are you up for it? Yes, Joe, give us all the data. Okay, Jenna, my turn. I am going to title my section, y'all are so crafty.
所以就是这样。现在，如果有人想分析吉姆花在恶作剧上的时间，我很乐意一读。乔，你准备好接单了吗？是的，乔，把所有数据交给我们。好的，珍娜，轮到我了。我给我的板块起名为：你们的手艺太巧了。
Because over the years, you have sent us so many things from scrunchies for our pets to cross-stitched items, drawings, personalized drinkware, jewelry, homemade stationary. That's just to name a few. I'm going to put a bunch of stuff in stories. We love to see what you guys make. We love a homemade craft. We make homemade craft. We do, not as well as these crafts. That's true. But I wanted to highlight Linda C, because she got super crafty over the holidays, and she made us each these little ugly Christmas sweater ornaments. And Sam and Cassie, she made you one too. Wait, wait, look.
因为这些年来，你们给我们送了好多东西，从我们宠物的发圈到十字绣物品、画作、个性化饮具、珠宝、自制信纸。这还只是其中一小部分。我会在动态里发一堆东西。我们很喜欢看你们制作的东西。我们喜欢自制手工艺品。我们自己也做手工艺品。是的，不过没这些手工艺品做得好。确实。但我想要表扬琳达·C，因为她在假期里变得心灵手巧，她给我们每个人都做了这些丑陋的圣诞毛衣小挂饰。萨姆和卡西，她也给你们俩各做了一个。等等，等等，看。
I can't even, with these, I can't. Oh my gosh! Look at Phyllis's Santa. And then little, little sweater. And then wait, hold, look, look, he's a cat, it's cat. Let me see this. Oh my gosh.
这太让我……我无话可说了。我的天哪！看菲莉丝的圣诞老人。然后还有小小的、小小的毛衣。然后等等，拿着，看，看，这是只猫，是猫。让我看看这个。我的天哪！
How cute is that? So cute. That segues me very well into something that I received for us, Angela. I'm excited to share. We each got beautiful handmade cardigan sweaters. They are from Michelle. Michelle said, I am a huge fan and I love the podcast.
这多可爱啊！这非常顺利地过渡到了我为我们收到的东西，安吉拉。我很激动能分享。我们每人都收到了漂亮的纯手工开衫毛衣。它们来自米歇尔。米歇尔说，我是超级粉丝，我超爱这个播客。
I listened at home while working on my latest clothing collection. I cut and sew everything by hand with a little help from my mom. I designed my clothing to be comfortable. It's actually my only criteria. Michelle. Michelle.
我在家里制作最新服装系列时会听。我所有的东西都是亲手裁剪和缝制的，在我妈妈的一点点帮助下。我设计的服装以舒适为主。其实这是我的唯一标准。米歇尔。米歇尔。
Michelle, who are you talking to? Michelle. Clothing, is it comfortable? Michelle goes on to say, I know you talking to? Michelle. Clothing. Is it comfortable? Michelle goes on to say, I know you gals are always cold. So hopefully this cold, we keep you warm. This is good news. Plus, they have pockets, and they are made in Winnipeg. And I hope you like them more than a bag of ketchup chips.
米歇尔，你在跟谁说话？米歇尔。服装，它舒服吗？米歇尔接着说，我知道你们在跟谁说话？米歇尔。服装。它舒服吗？米歇尔接着说，我知道你们这几个姑娘总是很冷。所以希望这件厚衣服能让你们保暖。这是个好消息。另外，它们有口袋，而且是在温尼伯制造的。我希望你们会喜欢它，胜过一包番茄味薯片。
Michelle, I love mine so much. I'm wearing it! Stop it! Woo! Woo! Woohoo! Oh! Woohoo! That looks like not something that a person could make. Oh, get out.
米歇尔，我太喜欢我的这件了。我正穿着呢！别这样！呜呼！呜呼！呜呼！哦！呜呼！这看起来不像是人能做出来的东西。哦，别开玩笑了。
Angela, here is yours. Ah! Ah! I love it! Ah! I love it! I love it! I love it. It's so comfy. The pockets are huge. You can find Michelle on Instagram at SliceGarves. Oh, I don't know what I'm like, oh!
安吉拉，这是你的。啊！啊！我太喜欢了！啊！我太喜欢了！我太喜欢了！我太喜欢了。太舒服了。口袋好大。你可以在Instagram上关注米歇尔，账号是SliceGarves。哦，我不知道我是怎么样的，哦！
Slice! Oh, I don't know what I'm like, oh, slide. All right, well, I want to share about Rowan. Rowan wrote in, Rowan is 16 years old, and wanted to share with us that in high school, she had really bad anxiety, and she would turn to the office on rough days, in particular season four, episode seven through 10. And Rowan went on to say that the show feels so calming and familiar and that because she knows the show so well, it feels like revisiting a childhood memory. I thought that was really sweet.
Slice！哦，我不知道我是怎么样的，哦，slide。好吧，我想分享一下关于罗文的事。罗文写信来了，罗文今年16岁，她想和我们分享她在高中时有很严重的焦虑症，在艰难的日子里她会看《办公室》，尤其是第四季第七到第十集。罗文接着说，这部剧感觉非常平静和熟悉，因为她对这部剧太熟悉了，感觉就像是在重温童年的记忆。我觉得这真的很甜。
She usually listens to us while she does her homework or paints and she wanted to say thank you for being there for her through a lot of her school years where she had anxiety. So she sent us each a nifty, gifty, and look. Oh my God. Okay, Jenna, she sent you a crocheted cactus because she said you had a hard time keeping plants alive, but this one can never die.
她通常在做作业或画画时听我们的节目，她想感谢我们在她经历焦虑症的很多学校时光里一直陪伴着她。所以她给我们每个人寄了一个精致的小礼物，你们看。我的天哪。好的，珍娜，她给你寄了一个钩针编织的仙人掌，因为她说你很难把植物养活，但这个永远不会死。
Oh. Thank you. And she made me a kitty cat. I know it's a podcast. The listeners can't see. But I'm going to put everything in stories. That is so cute. I'm going to put that on my desk at home.
哦。谢谢。她还给我做了一只小猫咪。我知道这是个播客。听众看不到。但我会把所有东西都发到动态里。太可爱了。我要把它放在我家里的书桌上。
I know. I have managed to keep my one plant alive that I would put in my podcasting closet when we were podcasting during the pandemic. It's the peace lily. And I think I bought it because I saw one on the show. And guys, it's still alive one year later. I'm so excited.
我知道。我成功把我那唯一的一盆植物养活了，我们在大流行期间录播客时，我会把它放在录音间里。那是一株白掌（和平百合）。我想我买它是、因为我在剧里看到过一株。伙计们，一年后它居然还活着。我太兴奋了。
That's amazing. Jenna, thank you. We're very proud of you. Thank you so much. You know your next challenge is an orchid. I've done an orchid line. Come on, you've kept one alive. Yes, because someone told me the secret.
太棒了。珍娜，谢谢你。我们为你感到骄傲。非常感谢。你知道你的下一个挑战是兰花。我已经养过兰花啦。拜托，你养活过一株。是的，因为有人告诉我秘诀。
What's the secret? One ice cube, once a week. Yes, and it works. And like filtered light. Oh, I didn't get that. No, what is filtered light? Well, like, it's not like the blaring sun, but it's maybe like through the blinds kind of light.
秘诀是什么？一周一块冰块。是的，而且管用。还有过滤光。哦，我没有那种。不，什么是过滤光？嗯，就不是那种刺眼的阳光，但可能是透过百叶窗的那种光。
Oh, okay. Yeah, okay. So that way your Orc doesn't end up like a little stick with a hair clip. You know. Well, okay. So that way your orchid doesn't end up like a little stick with a hair clip. You know. Well, it will do that. It will fall off, but then it will re-bloom. Have you ever had an orchid re-bloom?
哦，好吧。对，好吧。这样你的兰花就不会最后变成一根带着发夹的小棍子了。你知道的。好吧，好吧。这样你的兰花就不会最后变成一根带着发夹的小棍子了。你知道的。好吧，它确实会那样。它会掉落，但随后它会重新开花。你养过重新开花的兰花吗？
Yes. Same. When did it, was it like a monumental time in your life? Because I kept putting the ice cube in once a week, and it was months, months, but then all of a sudden, a re-bloom. It was one of the most exciting moments of my life. No, I had an orchid that was a stick with a hair clip for years,
有。我也是。那是你人生中具有重大意义的时刻吗？因为我坚持一周放一次冰块，过了几个月、几个月，然后突然间，它又开花了。那是我人生中最激动人心的时刻之一。不，我有一株兰花，多年来它就是一根带发夹的小棍子，
and I didn't give up on it, and I was not super happy in my life, and then I moved, and I put it in a new window, and maybe it was new beginnings for me in all of a sudden it bloomed. Ah! New beginnings for the orchid. Mm-hmm. New beginnings all around, new beginnings. All right, I want to talk about Catherine, who made us handmade leather journals. Do you remember?
我没有放弃它，那时我在生活中过得并不特别开心，然后我搬家了，把它放在一个新的窗户里，也许那是我的新开始，突然它就开花了。啊！兰花的崭新开始。嗯哼。全方位的崭新开始，新的开始。好的，我想聊聊凯瑟琳，她给我们制作了手工皮革日记本。你们还记得吗？
I talked about Catherine and that she makes handmade leather journals. Well, she was so thrilled that she sent us each our own handmade leather journal, but I want to read you guys what she put on the envelope. She said attention office ladies, care of Angela Kinsey, regarding semi-colon journals, male category, semi-colon threat level midnight. Jenna, your journal has a fakie flower and it's detachable so you can wear it. Mine has a vintage cat button that she has been saving for this very moment.
我提到了凯瑟琳，她制作手工皮革日记本。好吧，她太激动了，给我们每人寄了她亲手制作的手工皮革日记本，但我想读给你们听听她写在信封上的话。她说：“致办公室女孩，转交安吉拉·金西，关于分号日记，邮件类别，分号：午夜威胁级别。”珍娜，你的日记本上有一朵假花，它是可拆卸的，所以你可以把它戴上。我的日记本上有一个复古猫咪纽扣，她为这一刻留存了很久。
Also, she said, P.S. Podcast idea, Journal BFFs, and people read from their old journals, she said, I'll go first, call me. That's a great idea! All right, you have a little thank you flower.
此外，她还说，P.S. 播客创意，日记闺蜜，大家朗读他们旧日记里的内容，她说，我先来，打给我。这真是个好主意！好了，你有一朵小感谢花。
Oh, this is beautiful. Wow, this is really good work. She did say, Angela, you can write all the ridiculously stupid things you want in your journal. Oh, and there's a place for a pencil or a pen. I know, and these are all, this is like her hobby. All right. Let me find something here, Angela,
哦，太美了。哇，这手工真不错。她说，安吉拉，你可以在你的日记本里写所有你想要写的荒谬愚蠢的事情。哦，这里还有放铅笔或钢笔的地方。我知道，这些全都是，这就像是她的爱好。好吧。让我在里头找点什么，安吉拉，
because I was going to share a little bit about journaling. You are? Yes. This is because earlier this summer, I was reading The Splendid in the Vile by Eric Larson. You know this. This is a story of Winston Churchill's time as Prime Minister during World War II. And while I was reading it, I learned about something called the Mass Observation Project in England.
因为我本来想分享一点关于写日记的事。是吗？对。因为今年夏天早些时候，我在读埃里克·拉森写的《荒凉之城》（The Splendid and the Vile）。你知道这个。这是讲温斯顿·丘吉尔在二战期间担任首相期间的故事。当我在读它的时候，我了解到英国有一个叫“大众观察项目”（Mass Observation Project）的东西。
Okay. It is a journaling club. No. Yes, come on. Yes, and it's fascinating. It is fascinating. Listen to this. The Mass Observation Project was a social research organization that was started in 1937. research organization that was started in 1937 and its purpose was to record the everyday lives of British people through a panel of 500 volunteer observers and journalists. They kept diaries and they replied to open-ended questionnaires about everyday life. And then during the war, people are asked to
好吧。这是一个日记俱乐部。不会吧。是的，拜托。是的，而且它太迷人了。太迷人了。听这个。大众观察项目是一个始于1937年的社会研究组织。研究组织，其目的是通过由500名志愿观察员和记者组成的评审团，记录英国人的日常生活。他们写日记，并回答关于日常生活的开放式问卷。然后，在战争期间，人们被要求
record their feelings, their fears, news they heard, questions they still had, general observations about life and how it might be different from before the war, and Eric Larson used these archives from the Mass Observation Project to research his book. And he included a bunch of the passages in the book. And it is so fascinating. It is just absolutely amazing to read these quotes from people, right? The Mass Observation Project is still going on today. So if you wanted to start doing it, I just wanna say you can go to their website.
记录他们的感受、恐惧、听到的新闻、他们依然存有的疑问、对生活的一般观察，以及它可能与战前有何不同，埃里克·拉森利用大众观察项目的这些档案来研究他的书。他在书中收录了许多段落。这真是太迷人了。阅读这些来自人们的引言，绝对是令人惊叹的，对吧？大众观察项目至今仍在继续。所以如果你想开始做这件事，我只想说你可以去他们的网站。
They post their prompts seasonally, and you can even go back and see all the prompts from the past. So like, for example, in winter 1982, do you know what you're gonna be journaling about? Food and gardening. Okay, yes. Right? They had all these questions about what food do you buy?
他们会按季节发布他们的写作提示（prompts），你甚至可以回头查看过去所有的提示。所以，例如，在1982年冬天，你知道你要写关于什么的日记吗？食物和园艺。好吧，是的。对吧？他们有所有这些关于你买什么食物的问题？
What food do you prepare? Do you prepare different food for a special occasion? Angela, you could describe the bagel! Yes! I would describe the bagel. You would! And then I might write about some hummingbirds. It all fits!
你准备什么食物？你会为特殊场合准备不同的食物吗？安吉拉，你可以描述一下百吉饼！对！我会描述百吉饼。你会的！然后我可能会写一些关于蜂鸟的事。这太契合了！
Let me tell you about my roofus that keeps coming by and shoving everyone else out of the way. His name is Rufus? No, it's a type of hummingbird. Oh, the Rufus hummingbird. The Rufus hummingbird. I thought you had started naming them. Have you started naming them? Do they have names? No, it's a type of hummingbird. Oh, the roof is hummingbird. The roof is hummingbird. I thought you had started naming them. Have you started naming them?
让我跟你讲讲我的红尾蜂鸟（Rufus），它总是一直飞过来把别的鸟都挤开。它的名字叫鲁弗斯（Rufus）？不，那是一种蜂鸟。哦，鲁弗斯蜂鸟。鲁弗斯蜂鸟。我以为你开始给它们起名字了。你开始给它们起名字了吗？它们有名字吗？不，那是一种蜂鸟。哦，鲁弗斯蜂鸟。鲁弗斯蜂鸟。我以为你开始给它们起名字了。你开始给它们起名字了吗？
Do they have names? No, I call them mostly like Buddy, and then I have little lady, and then I need to do better with names. Okay. Do you like call somebody like Bluebelly? I-I-Mr. Fast Wings! No, I-
它们有名字吗？不，我通常叫它们“老兄”（Buddy），然后我还有“小小姐”，我在这方面还需要起得更好一点。好吧。你会叫别人像“蓝肚皮”这样的名字吗？我——我——“快翅先生”！不，我——
No. That's how I would name them. Okay. Like by their personality. And be like, oh, here's shy guy. Yeah. Yeah. You know. That's like how my sister names her cats.
没有。我就是这样给它们起名字的。好吧。比如根据它们的性格。然后说，哦，害羞鬼来啦。对。对。你知道的。就像我姐姐给她猫起名字的方式一样。
Like she has garage kitty. Because it showed up in her garage. Oh. Yeah. That's it. It's garage kitty. I would garage. Oh! Yeah. That's it. It's garage kitty. I would maybe do that.
比如她有“车库小猫”。因为它出现在她的车库里。哦。对。就这样。这就是车库小猫。我可能会那样做。
Well, anyway, I just found it really fascinating. You know, we've always talked about, we've even talked about with Billie Eilish, the value of journaling. And you read from your journal and it's always so great. But look at this. This is recording history, like journaling as a historical record. I thought it was fascinating. I absolutely love it. Anyway, everyone like journaling as a historical record. I thought it was fascinating. I absolutely love it. Anyway, everyone keeps journaling.
总之，我就是觉得它真的很迷人。你知道，我们一直在讨论，甚至和比利·艾利什也探讨过写日记的价值。你读你的日记，总是那么棒。但看看这个。这是在记录历史，就像把日记作为历史记录一样。我觉得太迷人了。我绝对太喜欢了。总之，大家继续写日记吧。
I love journaling. I love journaling. It's healthy. It's good for you. Also, it comes back around years later. So all right. Here's something I'm very, very excited to talk about, which is I get a lot of Star Wars mail.
我爱写日记。我爱写日记。这很健康。对你有好处。而且，多年后它还会回过头来给你惊喜。所以，好吧。接下来我要讲一件我非常非常兴奋的话题，那就是我收到了很多《星球大战》的邮件。
Uh-huh. Some of you that listen to the podcast will know why. It's because I love Star Wars. We have discussed Star Wars in depth on the show, and Jenna does not know Star Wars, and it wounded me in a way I still am not over. I'm sorry. Oh.
嗯哼。听播客的一些人会知道为什么。因为我爱《星球大战》。我们在节目中深入讨论过《星球大战》，而珍娜不懂《星球大战》，这深深地伤了我的心，直到现在我还没缓过来。我很抱歉。哦。
I know people were mad when I didn't know what a Jedi was. I know. Well, I was asking earnest questions. Well we got a fan mail flurry about your lack of Jedi knowledge, and I'm going to share some of it. But first I'm going to give a shout out to someone in the audience who made us adorable, mini baby Yoda's... Shae!
我知道当我不知道绝地武士是什么时，大家都很生气。我懂。好吧，我当时是在真诚地提问。好吧，我们收到了一阵关于你缺乏绝地知识的粉丝来信轰炸，我要分享其中的一部分。但首先我要向观众席中的某个人大声表白，她给我们做了可爱的、迷你版的尤达宝宝……谢伊！
They are so cute. Woo! Oh, you have one wickie. Oh my gosh. They are so adorable. Mine hangs in my office. I see it every day. Mine's on my bookshelf.
它们太可爱了。呜呼！哦，你有一个小维基。哦，天哪。它们太可爱了。我的挂在我的办公室里。我每天都能看到它。我的在我的书架上。
Same. I love it. I didn't want to put it on the tree because I didn't want the cats to mess with it. It lives in my office. And also I want to read a few letters from folks who have my same passion for Star Wars that Jenna does not. Here we go.
我也是。我超爱。我不想把它挂在树上，因为我怕猫咪去弄它。它住在我的办公室里。此外，我还想读几封信，写信的人有着和我一样的《星球大战》热情，而珍娜则没有。我们开始吧。
This is from Brian S. Hi office ladies. I'm in the middle of listening to Michael's last Dundees and the discussion on the Jedi's is making me spill my coffee all over my computer. I think it was Sam's quote, I'm so viscerally mad line that did it. It reminded me of Jim and Andy discussing Battlestar Galactica with Dwight listening behind them. To the point where I almost thought Jenna was faking her lack of Jedi knowledge, just to get a reaction. Sometimes these conversations are even better than the episode recaps. She was not faking Brian, she's very clueless about Jedi's.
这是布赖恩·S发来的。嗨，办公室女孩。我正在听迈克尔的最后一场邓迪奖，关于绝地武士的讨论让我把咖啡洒了一台电脑。我想是萨姆的那句台词，“我简直愤怒到骨子里了”，才引发了这一切。这让我想起了吉姆和安迪讨论《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》，而德怀特在他们身后偷听的情景。以至于我差点以为珍娜是在假装她不懂绝地武士，只是为了博取反应。有时这些谈话甚至比剧集回顾还要精彩。她不是在假装，布赖恩，她对绝地武士一无所知。
Robert D wrote in and said, first all, I love the show, I've listened to everyone so far, but secondly, while listening to the show, I had so many actual laugh-out-loud moments, mostly during the Star Wars Jedi discussion. I actually spoke out loud to the show, I had so many actual laugh-out-loud moments, mostly during the Star Wars Jedi discussion. I actually spoke out loud in the car. Angela, just stay calm! But I forgot there were other people in the studio with you, specifically Sam, Sam they call you out again. When he came on and said, I'm getting viscerally mad, I almost drove off the road.
罗伯特·D写信说，首先，我超爱这个节目，到目前为止每集我都听了；但其次，在听节目的同时，我有很多次忍不住大声笑出来的时刻，主要是在《星球大战》绝地武士的讨论期间。我在车里实际上大声对着节目喊出来了。安吉拉，冷静点！但我忘了录音室里还有其他人陪着你，特别是萨姆，萨姆，他们又点名你了。当他插话说，“我愤怒到骨子里了”，我差点把车开出路面。
Now, I'm very excited because we got a question from Lauren, who's in the audience today. Lauren from Fort Collins. Lauren, are you here? Yay! Woo! OK. Lauren wrote in and said, Angela, if you were a Jedi,
现在，我非常激动，因为我们收到了今天在现场的劳伦的问题。来自柯林堡的劳伦。劳伦，你在现场吗？耶！呜呼！好的。劳伦写信说，安吉拉，如果你是一个绝地武士，
what color would your lightsaber be? And where would you be from? Oh, Lauren. Oh, Lauren. Well, you know, some say that the color of your saber identifies you, right? Like Darth Vader's was red. Maybe he had some aggression clearly.
你的光剑会是什么颜色？你来自哪里？哦，劳伦。哦，劳伦。好吧，你知道的，有人说你光剑的颜色代表了你的身份，对吧？就像达和维德的是红色的。也许他身上显然有些攻击性。
And most Jedi's have blue lightsabers, which is supposed to represent righteousness. But I love race storylines so much and I love that her lightsaber at the end ends up being yellow and I like to think it's like new dawn, new beginnings, right? I'm see I'm a geek, I'm a total geek for Star Wars. So round about answer Lauren, yellow, I would like a yellow lightsaber please. And then as far as location, you know, yellow, I would like a yellow lightsaber, please. And then as far as location, you know, I'm kind of a sucker for old school,
而且大多数绝地武士都拥有蓝色的光剑，这本该代表正义。但我太喜欢蕾伊（Rey）的故事线了，我喜欢她最后的绝地光剑是黄色的，我喜欢认为这象征着“新曙光，新开始”，对吧？看，我是个极客，我是《星球大战》的超级极客。所以兜了个圈子回答你，劳伦，黄色，请给我一把黄色的光剑。然后至于地点，你知道的，黄色，请给我一把黄色的光剑。然后至于地点，你知道的，我有点偏爱老派风格，
like Forest Moon of indoor, because I wanna hang out with the Ewoks. I wanna go up in the trees. I wanna see their village. And I know, listen, I know on Kashyyyk, there's like a tree village thing too, but I gotta go with the Ewoks. But, you know, Jenna has no idea what I'm talking about.
比如恩多星的森林卫星（Forest Moon of Endor），因为我想和伊沃克人（Ewoks）一起玩。我想爬上树。我想参观他们的村庄。我知道，听着，我知道在卡西克（Kashyyyk）也有类似树屋村庄的地方，但我得选伊沃克人。但是，你知道的，珍娜根本不知道我在说什么。
I will admit that I don't understand a lot of what you said. However, I have an announcement. Sam, you might want to come in here for this. What? Does Sam know about it? No. You bring Sam in from the booth. I'm bringing Sam in from the booth. Did you meet Mark Hamill? What? Oh! No! No!
我承认我听不懂你说的很多东西。不过，我有重大宣布。萨姆，你可能想为此加入我们的对话。什么？萨姆知道这事吗？不知道。你把萨姆从录音间里叫出来。我把萨姆从录音间里叫出来了。你见到马克·哈米尔了吗？什么？不！不！
Luke Skywalker! I know who Luke Skywalker is because this lady watched Star Wars! Yeah! Yeah! That's it! So, you know, with my broken shoulder, I have to ice several times a day. Yeah. So this week while I was icing my shoulder I watched all of Star Wars from beginning to end without falling asleep once in 30 minute increments. You watched all the movies? My god, no. You, I watched Star Wars colon a new hope, which I want you to know was very confusing for me as I was calling through all of them.
卢克·天行者！我知道谁是卢克·天行者，因为这位女士看了《星球大战》！耶！耶！就是这样！所以，因为我骨折了，我每天必须冰敷好几次。对。所以这周当我冰敷肩膀时，我以每次30分钟的进度，从头到尾看完了所有的《星球大战》，中间一次也没有睡着。你把所有的电影都看完了？天哪，没有。你，我看的是《星球大战：第四部：新希望》（Star Wars: A New Hope），我想让你们知道，当我一部部翻看时，这把我搞得非常困惑。
Well, I have questions. I have questions, but I watched the whole thing. Okay. And I'll say this, because I have questions, but I want you to know. I liked it. Ah! Oh! What? Good.
好吧，我有问题。我有问题，但我看完了整部电影。好的。我要说的是，因为我有问题，但我希望你们知道。我挺喜欢的。啊！哦！什么？好。
What? How many years have you been on this planet? And you are, I have a long, if we've been friends and you've been throwing shade in Star Wars for years. Ah! Oh my God. I really liked it. So much so that I have started Empire's
什么？你在地球上待了多少年了？而你，如果说我们一直是朋友，而你多年来一直在对《星球大战》翻白眼。啊！我的天哪。我真的很喜欢。喜欢到我已经开始看《帝国反击战》了——
come on! Which is so good! Okay, so- So what are your questions? I can't imagine- I don't believe that she's like this. I can't. First of all, I just say this.
拜托！太好看了！好吧，所以——那么你有什么问题？我简直无法想象——我不相信她会这样。我真的不信。首先，我要说这个。
I don't believe it. I want to say something in my defense. So the first 23 minutes of the movie, because I looked, has no human protagonist. You meet Princess Leia for a hot second. Right. And then everybody is in a costume that covers their face or they're a robot or they're an R2. And they're in the sand.
为我自己辩护一下。电影的前23分钟，因为我注意到了，没有人类主角。你只瞥见了莱娅公主一眼。对。然后每个人都穿着遮住脸的服装，或者他们是机器人，或者他们是R2。而且他们都在沙子里。
Yeah. And it's like it takes a long time. Tatooine. Tatooine, Tatooine, Tatooine is a turtle. Yeah. Luke Skywalker, it takes a while. So I will say this, I was attached to R2D2 immediately. Like when they were gonna maybe not buy him
是的。而且这花了好长时间。塔图因。塔图因，塔图因，塔图因是个……（口误）是的。卢克·天行者，这花了好一阵子。所以我得说，我立刻就对R2D2产生感情了。就像当他们可能不打算买他时，
when they bought C3PO, my heart was racing, I was like, don't leave him behind. I know, he's very cute. So I was able to hook in, but in my childhood, I never made it to Luke Skywalker. I- You never made it 23 minutes. I didn't make it 23 minutes.
当他们买了C3PO时，我的心跳加速，我想，别把他落在后面。我知道，他非常可爱。所以我能够代入进去，但在我的童年里，我从没坚持看到卢克·天行者出场。我——你连23分钟都没坚持看完。我连23分钟都没坚持看到。
Too many robots. Yeah. Because I remember I had memories of the sand and all of that, and then I had no memories until the trash compactor, I think I had memories of the sand and all of that and then I had no memories until the trash compactor I think I woke up because I remembered from the trash compactor to the end. Okay. The middle part is great. The movie?
机器人太多了。是的。因为我记得我对沙子之类的一切都有记忆，然后我什么都不记得了，直到垃圾压缩机那段，我想我有从垃圾压缩机到片尾的记忆。好吧。中间部分很棒。电影吗？
Yeah. But here are a few of my questions. Okay. I don't understand Darth Vader's position in the hierarchy, in the hierarchy, because there seems to be a different guy that's in charge, and I don't understand who the ruler is, are the general, the guy who's calling all this, the one who blows up the planet.
对。但这里有我的几个问题。好的。我不明白达和维德在层级中的地位，在层级中，因为似乎有另一个负责人，我不明白谁才是统治者，或者将军，那个下令炸毁星球的家伙。
Yeah, yeah. I know, I know. That's the death star, lady. I know, you're I know. That's the death star, lady. I know. You're expecting us to react more. We've just, we've seen it. Yeah, I know. I know.
对，对。我知道，我知道。那是死星，大姐。我知道，你——我知道。那是死星，大姐。我知道。你期待我们有更激烈的反应。我们已经，我们看过了。对，我知道。我知道。
I know. This is new to you. Yeah, he does. He blows up the planet. We're like, yeah, crazy. He's a bad guy. Yeah, yeah. That's wild.
我知道。这对你来说是新鲜事。是的，他确实炸了。他炸毁了星球。我们的反应是，哦，太疯狂了。他是个坏人。对，对。太疯狂了。
So one of my questions is, why do they wear the white outfits? The stormtroopers? Why? What? Easy visibility, I guess. This is not the question I saw coming from you. Well, it's not armor, because you can shoot right through it very easily. It seems cumbersome.
所以我的问题之一是，他们为什么穿白色的制服？那些帝国冲锋队（Stormtroopers）？为什么？什么？我想是为了显眼吧。这可不是我预料你会提出的问题。嗯，那可不是盔甲，因为你可以很轻松地直接射穿它。看起来很笨重。
They seem to move more slowly because of it. They're less agile. It didn't make sense to me. I didn't understand why they forced their army to wear these outfits. Also clearly there's a height requirement because everyone is exactly the same size. It visually is very cool. It didn't make logical sense to me.
因为这身衣服，他们看起来行动更慢了。他们没那么敏捷。这对我来说毫无逻辑。我不明白他们为什么要强迫他们的军队穿这种制服。而且显然有身高要求，因为每个人都完全一样高。视觉上确实很酷。但在逻辑上对我毫无意义。
I didn't understand. You're gonna have to let go of logic. Yeah. Okay. I'm gonna have to keep watching until they get to the Clone Wars, which is a whole of movies about the stormtroopers and why they're the same height. Oh, will that be explained to me eventually if I keep going?
我不明白。你得放弃逻辑。好吧。我得继续看下去，直到他们看到《克隆人的进攻》（Clone Wars），那是一整套关于冲锋队员以及为什么他们身高一样的电影。哦，如果我继续看下去，最终会向我解释这些吗？
By the way, if you can watch really close the game, you're gonna hate it. Yeah. I guarantee it. If you watch really closely, I think it's an Empire Strike back. My friend and I would like watch it rewind, watch it rewind. One of the stormtroopers is just a little bit taller than everybody else, and they're all marching through the tunnel, and he hits his head and he goes all the way back. And comes back like a rubber band like mine. Oh, because he was a little bit too tall for the tunnel. Yeah. Background catch. I have a background catch from Star Wars, and I wonder if any of you noticed.
顺便说一句，如果你仔细看那场戏，你会讨厌它的。是的。我向你保证。如果你仔细看，我想是在《帝国反击战》里。我和我朋友会看倒带，看倒带。其中一个冲锋队员比其他人稍微高了一点，当他们列队穿过隧道时，他的头撞到了，然后他整个人弹了回去。像皮筋一样弹了回来。哦，因为他个子对那个隧道来说稍微高了一点。是的。背景穿帮。我发现了《星球大战》的一个背景穿帮，我想知道你们有没有注意到。
What? One of the guys, one of the leaders of the rebels Yes is Is explaining the information that they have gotten from the right where she the death star in the middle. That's right He says princess Leah Calls are princess Leah. He doesn't call her Leia. Oh, but they left that in. Yeah. Rude.
什么？其中一个人，叛军的一个领袖，是的，正在解释他们从正确那里得到的信息，中间有死星的那场。没错。他说的是“莱娅公主（princess Leah）”的呼叫。他没有叫她“莱娅（Leia）”。哦，但他们把这个留下了。是的。太粗鲁了。
You got a lot more. Love, love. Well, there you have it, guys. Well, I'm honored. I'm honored that you watched it. You thought it made me. Yes, I can't believe it, Sam. I'm in the middle of Empire Strikes Back.
你还有更多。爱，爱。好吧，事情就是这样，伙计们。好吧，我很荣幸。我很荣幸你能看它。你觉得这让我——是的，我简直不敢相信，萨姆。我正在看《帝国反击战》呢！
He just fought off the wormy creature and he's looking for Yoda. Yeah. Yoda. Yeah. Yoda. Yeah. It'll soon be clearer. Sam, we need to discuss. I feel like we need to download.
他刚刚击退了那个蠕虫般的生物，正在找尤达。对。尤达。对。尤达。对。很快就会更清楚了。萨姆，我们需要谈谈。我觉得我们需要交流一下。
All right. I can't believe you like it. It's going to take me a minute. I don't. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, wait. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Wait, we been friends? I don't know. 27? I don't love it, lady. I like it.
好吧。真不敢相信你喜欢它。这得花我一点时间。我才不。等等，等等，等等，等等。等等，等等，等等，等等。等等，等等。等等，等等，等等，等等。等等，我们是朋友吗？我不知道。27？我不喜欢它，女士。我喜欢它。
I like it. I like it. And you're going to get started. I'm in Star Wars merch. I'm in Star Wars merch. Enough. I don't want any merch. Get ready.
我喜欢它。我喜欢它。你要开始了。我穿着《星球大战》周边。我穿着《星球大战》周边。够了。我什么周边都不想要。准备好吧。
I have the Star Wars. I have the cutest Star Wars pajamas. Oh, boy. I got them at Target a few years ago. I don't know if they still make them, but get ready for Star Wars pajamas. I don't want to wear it. I don't want. I got them at Target a few years ago. I don't know if they still make them, but get ready for Star Wars. But I don't want to wear it. I don't want to wear it.
我有《星球大战》。我有最可爱的《星球大战》睡衣。哦，天哪。我几年前在塔吉特买的。我不知道他们还在不在生产，但准备好迎接《星球大战》睡衣吧。我才不想穿。我不想。我几年前在塔吉特买的。我不知道他们还在不在生产，但准备好迎接《星球大战》吧。但我不想穿它。我不想穿它。
Twining. But I might this Halloween. What? What? I might go as Princess Leia. Yes, no. In the outfit at the end of the movie when she's putting the medals on them, that's a white outfit with a braid and nothing necklace.
撞衫。但我今年万圣节可能会穿。什么？什么？我可能会扮成莱娅公主。好吧，不。电影结尾她给他们颁发勋章时的那套衣服，是一套白色的衣服，梳着辫子，戴着一条简单的项链。
There is a chance someone might mistake you for a bride. No. It's kind of a bridey vibe. It's a little bridey vibe. I'm sorry, you know the movie you won't miss me. Oh, shame! No, no, the star was shame. OK.
难保有人会把你错认成新娘。不会吧。有点新娘的氛围。有点新娘的氛围。不好意思，你知道这部电影，你不会错过我的。哦，真遗憾！不，不，这是星战的遗憾。好吧。
All right, well, I think we should take a break. Because when we come back, we have an audience question from Charles. Yay! Applause! Applause! This holiday season, Hershey's is warming hearts and melting boundaries to create a better sweeter world.
好吧，我想我们该休息一下了。因为当我们回来时，我们将解答来自查尔斯的一个观众提问。耶！鼓掌！鼓掌！这个节日季，好时（Hershey's）温暖着人心，打破着界限，创造一个更美好、更甜蜜的世界。
You know that traditional holiday cookie. It can be a little bit boring, but the ones with Hershey kisses on top are sure to be a huge hit. Oh, Angela, you know all about this. You know I do. You guys, my husband, Josh, made the cutest cookies. So here's the recipe. He did a gingerbread cookie, right? The little bit of spice in it.
你知道那种传统的节日饼干。可能会有点无聊，但上面放了好时Kisses巧克力的那些绝对会大受欢迎。哦，安吉拉，你对这个很了解。你知道的，我确实了解。你们知道吗，我丈夫乔希做了最可爱的饼干。食谱是这样的。他做的是姜饼，对吧？里面带有一点点香料。
And then in the middle, he put the Hershey's kiss candy cane. That's the one that's the white with the little red swirl. Yes. It's my favorite. That one is my favorite. I will bring some of these cookies in for you guys. And then everyone out there listening, I will put the recipe in our stories. It's so festive and cute. You're going to love it and delicious. Well, Josh is baking with kisses. I decorate with kisses because all the wrappers are so cute, you know, like they have the one with the little snowman. And remember earlier, when I said that my mom stole my Santa hat kisses?
然后中间放了一颗好时拐杖糖口味的Kisses。就是那种白色的，带有一点红色漩涡的。对。那是我的最爱。那个是我的最爱。我会带一些这种饼干来给你们尝尝。然后所有在听节目的朋友们，我会把食谱发到我们的动态里。又喜庆又可爱。你们一定会喜欢的，而且很美味。好吧，乔希是在用Kisses烘焙。我用Kisses来装饰，因为所有的包装纸都太可爱了，你知道的，比如上面有戴着小雪帽的那种。还记得刚才我说的吗，我妈妈偷了我那包圣诞帽Kisses？
Yeah. So the folks at Hershey's sent both of us these amazing gift baskets full of kisses. And I had it in my kitchen, my mom came to visit me and she goes, where did you get this bag of Santa hats? My store was out of Santa hat kisses. I need these. I need these for my elf. Let me explain. She has this elf candy dispenser
对。所以好时的朋友们给我们俩都寄了这些装满Kisses的惊艳礼品篮。我把它放在厨房里，我妈妈来看我，她说，你从哪弄来这一袋圣诞帽？我的店里没有圣诞帽Kisses了。我需要这个。我的小精灵需要这个。让我解释一下。她有一个这样的小精灵糖果分发器
and she likes the Santa hat kisses for it. It's a tradition. So she asked if she could have some and I said, of course, sure. And then, Angela, I'm not getting you. She took the entire bag and put it in her purse. She stole my bag of Santa hat. I just love bag and put it in her purse. She stole my bag of Santa half. I just love that she put them in her purse. She took these are going home with me.
她喜欢用圣诞帽Kisses来装。这是一个传统。所以她问能不能拿一些，我说，当然，没问题。然后，安吉拉，你绝对猜不到。她把整整一袋都拿走放进她的钱包里。她偷了我那一袋圣诞帽Kisses。我只是觉得她把它塞进钱包里的样子太可爱了。她拿了这些要带回家。
It was a huge bag. Well, you know, we took all of our Hershey kisses out of our basket and our cat Oreo took over the basket. So I got to keep the kisses, but she stole the basket. Well, if you want to decorate with kisses, or if you want to bake with them, check out Hershey's website. They also have a recipe on there for this adorable melting snowman cookie using the kisses. Hershey's Heart Worming the World Learn More at www.HersheyLand.com. Well, we are back, and like Angela said, we have a question from Charles and our audience Charles, I loved this question. Where are you?
那是一大袋。好吧，你知道的，我们把篮子里所有的好时Kisses都拿了出来，我们的猫奥利奥（Oreo）占领了这个篮子。所以我留下了Kisses，但她偷了篮子。好吧，如果你想用Kisses来装饰，或者想用它们来烘焙，去查看好时的网站吧。上面还有一个食谱，是用Kisses制作这个超级可爱的融化雪人饼干。好时：用心温暖世界。了解更多请访问 www.HersheyLand.com。好了，我们回来了，就像安吉拉说的，我们有来自观众查尔斯的一个问题，查尔斯，我太喜欢这个问题了。你在哪？
Hi. There you are. Alright, Charles asked which one-off character or guest star do you wish had a longer story arc and what do you imagine that arc might be? Such a good question. This is who came to mind to me immediately. Okay. Michael's improv teacher, Chris.
嗨。你在这儿。好的，查尔斯问，你希望哪个只出现过一次的角色或客串明星能有更长的主线剧情，你想象那条剧情会是什么样的？真是个好问题。这是我脑海中立刻浮现的人。好的。迈克尔的即兴表演老师克里斯。
Yes. He was played by Michael Noughton. I just, I would have loved to have seen more of the improv class, but then I thought, what if in order to try to manage Michael in the improv class, Chris was started reaching out to Dundermiflin employees to learn more about Michael in the improv class. Chris was started reaching out to Dunder Mifflin employees to learn more about Michael.
对。他由迈克尔·诺顿（Michael Noughton）扮演。我只是，我很想看到更多即兴表演课的内容，但后来我想，为了在即兴表演课上管住迈克尔，克里斯开始接触邓德米弗林的员工，以更多地了解迈克尔。即兴表演课上。克里斯开始接触邓德米弗林的员工，以更多地了解迈克尔。
Mm-hmm. Just if he invited Jim to lunch. Yeah. What might they talk about? I don't know. I would love to see that lunch. But there was another one too. Another storyline that never went anywhere
嗯哼。如果他邀请吉姆吃午饭。对。他们会聊些什么呢？我不知道。我很想看那场午饭。但还有另一个。另一条无疾而终的故事线
that I just wanted to see more of was Pam's administrative mentor Sue over in Vance Refrigeration, the one that Phyllis hated. Yeah, Phyllis doesn't like her outfit. I wanted to see more of Pam and Sue. I wanted to see Phyllis sabotage this relationship. I don't know. I would have loved to have seen that.
我只是想看到更多内容，那就是帕姆在万斯冷气公司（Vance Refrigeration）的行政导师苏，就是菲利斯讨厌的那个人。对，菲利斯不喜欢她的穿着。我想看到更多关于帕姆和苏的内容。我想看菲利斯破坏这种关系。我不知道。我很想看到那个。
I love that. Okay, well here's what I thought, Charles. OK, did you guys remember in season six, it's St. Patrick's Day, and everyone is staying late, because Joe is there, and Michael's like feeling like, oh, I can't let everyone leave. And they're there so late that the cleaning crew comes in with music blaring.
我喜欢那样。好吧，我是这么想的，查尔斯。好吧，你们还记得第六季里，那是圣帕特里克节，每个人都留得很晚，因为乔（Jo）在那儿，迈克尔觉得，哦，我不能让所有人离开。他们留得太晚了，清洁人员伴随着震耳欲聋的音乐走了进来。
Yes. And then they're like, oh, sorry, sorry. I want to know more about this cleaning crew. I was like, did, did, like, is there any footage of them? Did the documentary crew capture them? I want to know more about what they do after hours. Yes. Or like, when Dwight would sleep on the couch
对。然后他们说，哦，对不起，对不起。我想了解更多关于这个清洁人员的信息。我想的是，有没有，有没有关于他们的素材？纪录片摄制组拍到他们了吗？我想知道更多关于他们下班后做什么的事情。对。或者当德怀特睡在沙发上时
and be clean around him. Exactly. Exactly. And then also, you know, we recently watched trivia in season eight. I am obsessed with the receptionist at Saber. Same. Stephanie, like everything she says when she's like,
周围却被打扫干净。没错。没错。然后还有，你知道的，我们最近看了第八季里的智力竞赛。我迷上了赛博（Sabero/Sabre）的前台接待员。我也是。斯蒂芬妮，她说的每句话，当她说的时候，
that must be so frustrating for you. Yes, everything. I want to know more about her. Maybe she has a gym. Maybe she has like this love in her office. But with sidebar kind of snarky comments, I don't know. I like all of it. I want to see those folks. Charles, we want to know if you have an answer to your question.
那对你来说一定很沮丧吧。对，每句话。我想更多地了解她。也许她有个健身房。也许她的办公室里有这样一份爱情。但带着一点局外人的尖酸刻薄的评论，我不知道。我喜欢所有这些。我想看到那些人。查尔斯，我们想知道你对你的问题有什么答案吗？
Thank you for having me. I kind of want to know what happened to Kevin MacAils character after he was kidnapped. Yes, did they refuse to ever deliver pizza to us again? Yeah. Yes. How does he tell that story to others? Yes. I like it. That's a good one. I like it. Thank you so much. So much.
谢谢邀请我。我其实挺想知道凯文·马龙（Kevin Malone）的角色被绑架后怎么样了。对，他们是不是拒绝再给我们送披萨了？对。对。他是怎么把这个故事讲给别人听的？对。我喜欢。这是一个好问题。我喜欢。非常感谢。非常感谢。
Thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you. One of the things I loved about that question, too, is it just really made me think about all of the characters that just had one off over the course of the 90s and there are so many rich, amazing day players that came on the show. I did also think of Moraterni as Mrs. California. And how much I would have loved for them to have maybe, I don't know, what if Mrs. California
非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。关于那个问题，我也很喜欢的一点是，它真的让我想起了在90年代期间只出现过一次的所有角色，剧里有那么多丰富、精彩的客串演员。我也想到了莫拉·蒂尔尼（Maura Tierney）饰演的加利福尼亚太太。我很希望他们能，我不知道，如果加利福尼亚太太
and Andy started dating? Right? And that's the best. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no So, I would love to give a shout out to everyone that sends us invitations to their weddings. We get so many. I open every single one. You know, we divide up the mail, but we go through it all. I had a stack of wedding invitations. My son came in my office and said, are we invited to all of those weddings?
和安迪开始约会会怎么样？对吧？那是极好的。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，安吉拉，我得告诉你们，向所有给我们发婚礼请柬的人致敬。我们收到了好多。每一封我都打开了。你知道的，我们分拣邮件，但我们全部都看完了。我有一叠婚礼请柬。我儿子走进我办公室说，我们受邀参加所有这些婚礼吗？
Because I think he thinks, oh, I have to wear suit. You know what I mean? We do divide up the mail mail and I want you to know that I always make sure that Angela gets all the wax seals. I'm very excited about that. I love a wax seal. I love a wax seal. And then I also love all the little details.
因为我觉得他以为，哦，我得穿西装。你知道我的意思吗？我们确实分拣邮件，我想让你知道，我总是确保安吉拉能拿到所有的蜡封。我对这个感到非常兴奋。我喜欢蜡封。我喜欢蜡封。然后我也喜欢所有的那些小细节。
I'm gonna share two really quickly. I just appreciate so much the thought that people put into their invites. So Scott and Victoria and Arroyo Grande, California, they did a Polaroid but they made it a magnet. This they're safe the day. That's so cute. I really love a magnet as a safe the day. Me too, because you're not going to miss it. No. Yeah. And you get a photo of people you care about. And then this I thought was so cute. This envelope says with love from the future fritzes.
我快速分享两个。我非常感激人们在请柬上投入的心思。所以加利福尼亚州阿罗约格兰德的斯科特和维多利亚，他们做了一张宝丽来照片，但把它做成了磁贴。这是他们的请柬。这太可爱了。我真的很喜欢把请柬做成磁贴。我也是，因为你不会错过它。对。对。而且你可以得到一张你在乎的人的照片。然后我觉得这个太可爱了。这个信封上写着：来自未来弗里茨夫妇的爱。
And please show the wax seal. Did I say? Did I say? Sorry, yes, wax seal. Oh, applause for wax seal. You love it. I love it. So this is Katie and Jared, and they're the future fritzes.
请展示一下蜡封。我刚才说了吗？我刚才说了吗？抱歉，是的，蜡封。哦，为蜡封鼓掌。你喜欢它。我喜欢它。所以这是凯蒂和贾里德，他们是未来的弗里茨夫妇。
And they have a few items here, but it's all paper clipped with a little letter F. That is so cute. Isn't that so cute? These are things I get excited about, you guys. I don't know what it says about where I'm at in life, but you send me a paperclip in the shape of your last name. I'm gonna get excited.
他们这里有几件东西，但都用一个小F字形的曲别针夹在一起。这太可爱了。是不是超级可爱？这些都是让我感到兴奋的事情，伙计们。我不知道这说明了我人生的哪个阶段，但如果你给我寄一个做成你姓氏形状的曲别针。我就会很兴奋。
And, oh my goodness, this is something that I really want to share. So we also, obviously, we get a lot of invitations to baby showers and graduations. So many young people graduated this year from high school and college and synesthr graduation invitations. And I want to share a letter we received from Spencer and Bellingham, Washington. She wrote to us and said that we really helped her get through college.
噢天哪，这是我真的很想分享的一件事。所以我们还收到，显而易见，我们收到了很多婴儿满月酒和毕业典礼的请柬。今年有那么多年轻人从高中和大学毕业，并寄来了毕业请柬。我想分享我们收到的一封来自华盛顿州贝灵厄姆的斯潘塞的信。她写信给我们说，我们真的帮她度过了大学生活。
She just received her BA in early childhood development. And she went on to say that during the pandemic, she took up running, and she would listen to the podcast as she ran, but unfortunately in 2022, she got long COVID and ultimately had to have surgery on a blockage in her femoral artery, and during that time, she couldn't listen to the podcast.
她刚刚获得了幼儿发展学士学位。她接着说，在大流行期间，她开始跑步，跑步时她会听播客，但不幸的是，在2022年，她得了长新冠，最终不得不做手术治疗股动脉阻塞，在那期间，她没法听播客。
But now she is post-surgery and she can walk again and she said it's so motivating, even when it's really painful as she regains her muscles that she gets to hear our voices again. And that just meant so much to me. I just know that we're there for her and Spencer, if you hear this and you're listening to us right now as you're on a walk,
但现在她已经做完手术，可以重新走路了，她说这太鼓舞人心了，即使在她重新恢复肌肉力量的过程中真的很痛苦，她又能听到我们的声音了。这对我意义重大。我知道我们在那里陪伴着她，斯潘塞，如果你听到这个，此刻正在散步时听着我们说话，
I just want you to know I'm thinking of you. That means so much to me too. You know, Spencer, in my own way, I can relate a little bit back in April, I broke my shoulder, which I am still rehabbing. I've got tape on it today. It's going to be about a year they said before I'll have a fully functioning shoulder. And so I just know what it is like to have to fight just to have an ordinary day with nothing extra in it. And also how the triumph that it is to be able to go on that first walk. Yeah. Post-long COVID, post-surgery. And so I just want to say to you, Spencer, keep fighting. I'm over here fighting my fight. I know there's a lot of other people out there doing their thing
我只想让你知道我在想着你。这对我来说也意义重大。你知道的，斯潘塞，用我自己的方式，我能感同身受一点，在四月份，我摔断了肩膀，我现在仍在康复中。我今天还在上面贴着胶带。他们说大约需要一年的时间，我的肩膀才能完全恢复功能。所以我很清楚，仅仅为了过上一个没有额外负担的普通日子而去奋斗是什么感觉。也知道能够去进行第一次散步是多么大的胜利。对。经历长新冠和手术之后。所以我只想对你说，斯潘塞，继续加油。我在这里也在为我的战斗而努力。我知道还有很多其他人也在做着他们的事情
to fight their fight. We all have something, right? We all have the thing we carry with us. We've talked about that even with anxiety in your backpack. Sometimes your backpack is chronic physical pain. Sometimes your backpack is a medical issue. But we're just gonna stay in it. We're gonna stay in it together.
来为自己的生活而战。我们每个人都有要面对的事情，对吧？我们每个人都有随身携带的东西。我们在背包里甚至讨论过焦虑的问题。有时你的背包是长期的身体疼痛。有时你的背包是一个医疗问题。但我们要坚持下去。我们要一起坚持下去。
And if this podcast gives you any relief, that brings me so much joy because doing this podcast gives me relief. Oh, lady. Thank you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you.
如果这个播客能给你带来任何宽慰，这会给我带来巨大的快乐，因为做这个播客也给了我宽慰。哦，老天。谢谢。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。
I love you, guys. I love you. I love you, guys. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you.
我爱你们，伙计们。我爱你们。我爱你们，伙计们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。
I love you, guys. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you, guys.
我爱你们，伙计们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们，伙计们。
I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. Now, I do want to share also about couples that listen to our podcasts in their courtship. It means so much to me. I just think it's so adorable. And a lot of you write in about it, especially when you send your wedding invitations and save the dates. And I got one also, Jenna, about our audiobook. So Josh and Jenny wrote in from Madison, Wisconsin.
我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。我爱你们。现在，我还想分享一下在追求爱慕期间听我们播客的情侣。这对我意义重大。我只是觉得太可爱了。你们中的许多人写信来讲述这个，特别是当你们寄来婚礼请柬和请柬时。詹娜，我还收到了一封关于我们的有声书的信。来自威斯康星州麦迪逊的乔希和珍妮写信说，
They are getting married this summer, and they said, Jenna and Angela, we listen to your podcast on every long drive we make, and we loved your audiobook. Thanks for keeping us sane and laughing. And I don't know Jenny and Josh, but I pictured the two of them in their car on a long commute, and you and I are just like, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah So, book club. Yeah, yeah. We did a Zoom with all the members of her book club. Well, there were several people in that book club who have never watched the office, and we got letters, and they said,
他们今年夏天要结婚了，他们说，詹娜和安吉拉，我们在每一次的长途驾驶中都会听你们的播客，我们非常喜欢你们的有声书。感谢你们让我们保持理智并带来欢笑。我不认识珍妮和乔希，但我脑海中浮现出他们俩在长途通勤的车里，而你和我就像是在，啦啦啦啦啦啦，啦啦啦啦啦，那么，读书俱乐部。对，对。我们和她读书俱乐部的所有成员进行了一次Zoom连线。好吧，那个读书俱乐部里有几个人从未看过《办公室》，我们收到了信，他们说，
I'm glad I read your book, because then I started watching the office, and then I realized you had a podcast, but who could have imagined that the book would be the way in? I know, I'm so glad. I'm so glad that they've gotten like nine seasons of entertainment. I can't even believe that. That's crazy. Yeah. Speaking of books, you know, lady, for a long time,
我很高兴我读了你们的书，因为后来我开始看《办公室》，然后我意识到你们有个播客，但谁能想到这本书会是切入点呢？我知道，我太高兴了。我很高兴他们能获得整整九季的娱乐。我简直不敢相信。这太疯狂了。对。说到书，你知道的，女士，很长一段时间以来，
we have talked about starting a book club. I might have our very first book. Okay, you told me that you were going to do this. So I want you to know, I don't know what her book is. Yeah. I also have a book. Oh, yeah. Yes. All right. Well, there's no way you can guess my book. There's no way. You're never guessing my book.
我们一直在讨论办一个读书俱乐部。我可能有了我们的第一本书。好吧，你告诉过我要这么做。所以我想让你知道，我不知道她的书是什么。对。我也有本书。哦，对。对。好吧，你绝对猜不到我的书。绝对不可能。你永远猜不到我的书。
OK. This, oh well, you're not guessing my book. OK. OK. So my book was sent to me from Mary W. She said, dear Angela, I work at a library. And when I first saw this title, I immediately thought of you.
好吧。这个，哦好吧，你猜不到我的书。好吧。好吧。所以我的书是玛丽·W寄给我的。她说，亲爱的安吉拉，我在图书馆工作。当我第一次看到这个书名时，我立刻想到了你。
You got to look at the title of this book. Here it is. I'm very intrigued. It's hot to try. Hot to try. No. Yep, Mary goes on to say, maybe it will inspire a plot for mom detectives. Which she's very much looking forward to, and I'll tell you why. Mary, I cannot wait to read this book.
你得看看这本书的书名。在这儿呢。我很感兴趣。热切尝试（Hot to trot）。热切尝试。没有。是的，玛丽接着说，也许它会激发“妈妈侦探”的故事情节。她非常期待这一点，我来告诉你为什么。玛丽，我迫不及待地想读这本书了。
Hot to trot is part of a mystery series. No, it is not. By MC Beaton, here's a summary for Hot to trot, which by the way has a little mystery spyglass thingy on the front, and it says queen of the village mystery. Here we go. Private detective Agatha Raisin immerses herself in the glittering lifestyle of the fabulously wealthy
《热切尝试》是一个悬念系列的一部分。不，它不是。作者是M·C·比顿（MC Beaton），这里是《热切尝试》的故事梗概，顺便说一句，封面上有一个小悬念放大镜之类的东西，上面写着“乡村神秘事件女王”。我们开始吧。私家侦探阿加莎·Raisin沉浸在极其富有的奢华生活方式中
when Sir Charles Freyth is accused of murder. And Agatha is named as his accomplice, a high society wedding, a glitzy mast ball, and an introduction to the world of international show jumping where the riders are glamorous, the horses are beautiful, and entry runs deep. Leaving Agatha with a list of suspects as long as a stallion's tail. Agatha must uncover the truth before a net of skulled duggery closes around them. And if events weren't complicated enough,
查尔斯·弗莱思爵士被控谋杀，阿加莎被指控为他的同谋，还有一场上流社会的婚礼、一场耀眼的化装舞会，以及对国际场地障碍赛世界的介绍——那里的骑手光彩照人，马匹美丽动人，门槛极高。这让阿加莎留下一串长得像种马尾巴一样的嫌疑人名单。阿加莎必须在层层阴谋织成的网收紧之前查明真相。如果事情还不够复杂的话，
Agatha's ex-husband James Lacey is back in Carstley and back in Agatha's heart. Pfft. Wow. Hut to trot. I was gonna ask you if the Hut to trot meant angry or if it meant... I know it to mean, but it clearly is in relation to the horses. Oh well, trotting.
阿加莎的前夫詹姆斯·莱西回到了克斯特利，也回到了阿加莎的心中。噗。哇。跃跃欲试。我刚才想问你，“跃跃欲试”是指生气还是指……我知道它的意思，但它显然和马有关。哦，好吧，小跑。
Well, hot to trot is about this glitzy world of show jumping. Yes. But it's also about James Lacey being back in her heart. She's hot to try. Yes. Can I share my book with you? Yes. Okay, this was a tip sent in by Lea W.
好吧，“跃跃欲试”与这个耀眼的场地障碍赛世界有关。是的。但这也关乎詹姆斯·莱西重新回到她的心中。她迫不及待地想试试。是的。我能跟你分享我的书吗？是的。好的，这是莉亚·W发来的线索。
After our interview with BJ Novak. Okay. Mr. Maybe. Oh! You don't want to be a Mr. Maybe. Yeah, because in our interview, I said, I don't want to Mr. Maybe. You did.
在我们采访完B·J·诺瓦克之后。好的。备胎先生。哦！你可不想当个备胎先生。是的，因为在我们的采访中，我说过，我不想当个备胎先生。你确实说过。
Well, there's a book called Mr. Maybe I bought it. I think it came out back in like 1999 early 2000s and the plot is a little dated Okay, so here's what it says I have to type it out cuz I can't read the back It says our main character is Libby Mason. And it says, to Libby Mason, Mr. Wright has always meant Mr. Rich. Oh. Yes. So here's the thing.
嗯，有一本书叫《备胎先生》，我买了一本。我想它是在1999年或2000年初出版的，情节有点过时了。好吧，它是这么写的，我得把它打出来，因为我看不清封书背面。上面写着，我们的主角是莉比·梅森。上面说，对莉比·梅森来说，真命天子一直意味着富有的人。哦。是的。所以情况是这样的。
Libby is dating a sexy, struggling writer named Nick, but she won't commit to him because he's not wealthy. But then she meets Ed, who is, quote, Britain's wealthiest but stodgiest bachelor. Oh, stodgy. Mm-hmm. Libby soon finds herself weighing the advantages of Nick's sexual prowess and tender heart,
莉比在和一个性感但苦苦挣扎的作家尼克约会，但她不愿承诺给他名分，因为他不够富有。但后来她遇到了埃德，用书里的话说，他是“英国最富有但最古板的单身汉”。哦，古板。嗯哼。莉比很快发现自己在权衡尼克的性能力和温柔心肠的好处，
sexual prowess. Yes. Against Ed's luxurious lifestyle and unlimited retail therapy. So Libby's trying to decide between these two guys. Oh my god, Libby, Libby, Libby. Libby, I just have to say, sexy tender-hearted, this is not a hard decision.
性能力。是的。与埃德的奢华生活方式和无限的零售疗法相比。所以莉比正在这两个男人之间做决定。天哪，莉比，莉比，莉比。莉比，我不得不说，性感又温柔，这并不是一个很难做出的决定。
You're going with sexy tender-hearted. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So that's why I say this is kind of dated. Ladies, I don't feel like this is our struggle today. We're not, we're all picking sexy tender hearted. I think, right? This reminded me, though, of that... Of course we are. I would say yes. I can't speak for everybody. Well, I don't know. Someone might want Stagy with benefits. I don't know. Staggie and an unlimited bank. I mean, you make poor ed sound horrible in the back cover.
你要选那个性感又温柔的。好的。对。所以我才说这有点过时了。女士们，我觉得这不是我们今天的挣扎。我们才不会，我们都会选那个性感又温柔的。我想，对吧？不过这让我想起了那个……当然会。我敢说会。我不能代表所有人。嗯，我不知道。也许有人想要带福利的古板男。我不知道。古板男配无限额的银行账户。我是说，你在封底把可怜的埃德说得太可怕了。
I mean, maybe he has other quality. Wait, Dean, maybe he's handsome, but Thunzei. I don't know. This did remind me of that quote from Cher. That I love. I love this quote. I love it. You know it.
我是说，也许他有别的品质。等等，迪安，也许他很帅，但有点乏味。我不知道。这确实让我想起了雪儿的那句名言。我好喜欢。我太爱这句名言了。我爱死它了。你知道的。
When her mom told her to settle down in Marriott Richman and Cher said, Mom, I am a rich man. That's right, Shera. You tell us. All right, and now for my bird people, I have a fellow hummingbird fan in the audience who made me a hat to feed hummingbirds. Made you? Made me a hat to feed hummingbirds? Made you? Made me a hat.
当她妈妈让她安定下来嫁个有钱人时，雪儿说：“妈，我自己就是个有钱人。”没错，雪儿。说得好。好了，现在轮到我的鸟类爱好者了，观众中有一位同好的蜂鸟粉丝，她给我做了一顶用来喂蜂鸟的帽子。给你做了一顶？给我做了一顶用来喂蜂鸟的帽子？给你做了一顶？给我做了一顶帽子。
Michelle, I'm going to eat it. Oh! Oh, my God! Okay. All right. I'm going to take a picture of you. Michelle, please come up here. Michelle, I have some questions for you about this hummingbird hat.
米歇尔，我要把它吃掉。哦！哦，天哪！好吧。好吧。我要给你拍张照。米歇尔，请上来。米歇尔，我有一些关于这顶蜂鸟帽子的问题想问你。
First of all, does this hummingbird hat work? Will they come? Yes, you have video proof of this. Okay, my Instagram. Yes, we'll have to share. You've used it. It's a straw hat. She's put flowers on it and the little hummingbird thingy pods.
首先，这顶蜂鸟帽子有用吗？它们会来吗？是的，你有视频证据。好吧，我的Instagram。是的，我们得分享一下。你用过它。这是一顶草帽。她在上面放了花和放糖水的小豆荚。
You just got to put some sugar water in it. Put some sugar water in it. How still and how long did you have to sit before your first hummingbird came? It depends. You have to sit very still. And the first couple times they came because they flutter up to you, I jerked away, but you get used to them coming so close. Okay, oh my god, I can't wait. Also, any tips in wearing the hummingbird hat that you've learned with your experience? The only thing I do is remove all the other feeders, like take away the other food sources
你只需要在里面放点糖水。在里面放点糖水。在你迎来第一只蜂鸟之前，你必须坐得多么一动不动、持续多久？这得看情况。你必须坐得非常安静。前几次它们来的时候，因为它们会扑扇着翅膀飞向你，我吓得猛地缩了回去，但你慢慢就会习惯它们靠得这么近。好的，哦天哪，我等不及了。另外，关于戴蜂鸟帽子，你有什么从经验中学到的建议吗？我唯一做的就是移除所有其他的喂食器，比如拿走其他食物来源，
so that you are the only food site, the food store. Yeah. You can double it with the shield, because you have a shield doing it. I do, I also, I got a shield for my birthday. A what? Josh got me, in fact, I opened Michelle's hummingbird hat first and he was like, dang it, Michelle! Because he got me. It's like, I don't know, Michelle, how do you describe
这样你就是唯一的觅食地点、粮仓。是的。你还可以搭配一个防护面罩，因为你戴着它操作。确实，我还有一个，我生日时得到了一个防护面罩。什么？乔斯送给我的，事实上，我先打开了米歇尔送的蜂鸟帽子，然后他说：“可恶，米歇尔！”因为他给我准备了。这就像是，我不知道，米歇尔，你该怎么形容它？
it? It looks like a show. You know those COVID face masks things? Yeah. We have one and I upcycled it into a DIY hummingbird theater, but you, they basically come up to your face and you have your face and is amazing. Oh wow! Yeah, okay. The shield covers your face like you're like you're a welder. Yes, you're like you're not. You have little hummingbird pods on your face. It's not weird.
它看起来像个演出。你知道那些新冠病毒面罩之类的东西吗？是的。我们有一个，我把它改造升级成了一个DIY蜂鸟剧院，但是你，它们基本上会飞到你的脸前，你的脸就在那儿，太神奇了。哦哇！是的，好吧。面罩盖住你的脸，就像你是个电焊工一样。是的，就像你不是。你脸上有小蜂鸟豆荚。这并不奇怪。
I have a question. Okay. Would you like want to wear sunglasses or something? Because it would like further trick them because they can't see your eyes. I don't know why. Do you think hummingbirds are gonna look me directly in the eye? I don't know because their eyes are so little but they like as a predator like if they think you're like if you sit really still with your hat and your shield and your eyes behind sunglasses. Michelle when I started wearing this cool hat,
我有一个问题。好的。你会想戴太阳镜什么的吗？因为这会进一步迷惑它们，因为它们看不到你的眼睛。我不知道为什么。你觉得蜂鸟会直勾勾地盯着我的眼睛看吗？我不知道，因为它们的眼睛太小了，但它们会把这当成捕食者——如果你戴着帽子和面罩，眼睛藏在太阳镜后面，一动不动地坐着……米歇尔，当我刚开始戴这顶酷帽子的时候，
I would wear sunglasses, because I was afraid they were going to like poke my eyes out. But they never did. Don't worry. No, I don't. OK. I was seeing it as like a way to make them feel safe, not as like for your safety.
我会戴着太阳镜，因为我害怕它们会戳到我的眼睛。但它们从来没有这样做过。别担心。不，我不会。好吧。我把它看作是一种让它们感到安全的方式，而不是为了你自己的安全。
I've heard they can recognize faces. I don't know if that's true, but they get used to you. So they'll be in dear to you. Okay, I can't wait. Thank you, Michelle. Yay! Angela, would this be a good time for me to share about some mail that we received over the Jim and Pam's first kiss controversy? Yes, we are still getting mail about this.
我听说它们能认出人的脸。我不知道这是否属实，但它们会习惯你。所以它们会亲近你。好的，我等不及了。谢谢你，米歇尔。耶！安吉拉，现在是个好时机让我分享一下我们收到的关于吉姆和帕姆初吻争议的邮件吗？是的，我们还在收到关于这方面的邮件。
Yes. Was it the Dundees? Was it Casino Knight? I know my feeling. I know. And I know that you tried to prove your point that it happened at the Dundees because in the show, Michael's last Dundees,
是的。是邓迪奖之夜吗？还是赌场之夜？我知道我的感觉。我懂。而且我知道你曾试图证明你的观点，即它发生在邓迪奖之夜，因为在剧中，迈克尔最后的邓迪奖，
you found some new dialogue in the script. I'm gonna reshare it to refresh our memory. You shared that there was a scripted line that got cut out, but Michael was going to describe the dundies this way. Quote, it's a magical night, D'Angelo, and not just because we recognize fellow employees, people fall in love. Pam and Jim had their first kiss there.
你在剧本中发现了一些新的台词。我将重新分享它来刷新我们的记忆。你分享说有一句被删掉的台词，迈克尔当时打算这样描述邓迪奖。原话是：“这是一个神奇的夜晚，迪安杰罗，不仅仅是因为我们表彰了同仁，人们还坠入了爱河。帕姆和吉姆在那里有了他们的初吻。”
And then the script said, Pam and Jim look at each kiss there. And then the script said, Pam and Jim look at each other and smile a little. That's true. Well, in that podcast, you kind of convinced me because I've been saying that it was Casino Knight. Paul B. and Minnesota, Paul is the pastor at Minnesota United Methodist Church. He wrote in, and he had this to say,
然后剧本上写着，帕姆和吉姆看着彼此，笑了一下。确实如此。好吧，在那期播客中，你算是说服了我，因为我之前一直说那是赌场之夜。明尼苏达州的保罗·B，保罗是明尼苏达联合卫理公会教堂的牧师。他写信来了，他是这么说的：
Pastor Paul wrote in, y'all. Yes. Love the pod, y'all are the best. I'm writing to say that despite what the script appears to say, I am still firmly in the camp that Jim and Pam's first kiss was not at the dundies. Oh, Pastor Paul! Yes. Paul says, I appreciate y'all, said y'all. I appreciate y'all sticking to the script since everything has to be consistent, but the script doesn't say that their first kiss was at the Dundies.
保罗牧师写信来了，各位。是的。超爱播客，你们是最棒的。我写信是想说，尽管剧本似乎是那么写的，但我仍然坚定地站在吉姆和帕姆的初吻不是在邓迪奖之夜的那一边。哦，保罗牧师！是的。保罗说，我很感激你们大家，用了“大家”。我很感激你们大家坚持剧本，因为所有事情都必须保持一致，但剧本并没有说他们的初吻是在邓迪奖之夜。
It says Michael Scott says their first kiss was at the Dundies, and of course he would say that because he wants matchmaker cred. This is his evidence of the magic that is the Dundies. So this is Michael's perception of what happened. Because he's trying to brag about the Dundies. Paul goes on to say yes. The script says that Jim and Pam look at each other and smile, but I think it could be because Jim and Pam have an ongoing debate about the kiss as well.
上面说迈克尔·斯科特说他们的初吻是在邓迪奖之夜，他当然会这么说，因为他想要红娘的功劳。这是邓迪奖具有魔力的证据。所以这是迈克尔对所发生事情的看法。因为他试图吹嘘邓迪奖。保罗接着说，是的。剧本上说吉姆和帕姆相视一笑，但我认为这可能是因为吉姆和帕姆对这个吻也有持续的争论。
Pastor Paul has thought a lot about this. Yes. Pastor Paul says, perhaps Jim, like John, thinks it was their first kiss, but Pam, like Jenna, believes that it was casino night. And then Paul says, be strong, Jenna, be strong! Don't let Angela Corruptor think in. We also got a letter from Gabrielle S. She's a schoolteacher
保罗牧师对此进行了很多思考。是的。保罗牧师说，也许吉姆像约翰一样，认为那是他们的初吻，但帕姆像珍娜一样，认为那是赌场之夜。然后保罗说：“坚强点，珍娜，坚强点！别让安吉拉腐蚀了你的想法。”我们还收到了一封来自加布里埃拉·S的信。她是一名学校老师，
in Alabama who said this, as I have listened to every episode of the podcast, I have been following the back and forth discussion about when Jim and Pam had their first kiss. And I was very surprised to hear Jenna concede that it might not be casino night. Then Gabrielle says this. So I'm eating an English muffin this morning. Is this my journal?
来自阿拉巴马州，她写道：“当我收听了播客的每一集时，我一直在关注关于吉姆和帕姆是什么时候有初吻的来回讨论。听到珍娜承认那可能不是赌场之夜，我非常惊讶。”然后加布里埃拉说：所以我今天早上一边吃着英式马芬，
While watching Goodby Tobey Part 1, and Jim shared with Michael when he and Pam had their first kiss. It is at 14 minutes and 28 seconds and he says, the first time we kissed was right outside, thus making it clear that even Jim believes their first kiss was Casino Knight, Jenna, you should have stood your ground. So I went back, I rewatched it, and in the scene, Jim is trying to explain to Michael
一边看《告别托比》第一集，吉姆跟迈克尔分享了他和帕姆是什么时候有初吻的。在14分28秒的时候，他说：“我们第一次接吻就在外面。”这就很清楚了，连吉姆都认为他们的初吻是赌场之夜，珍娜，你本该坚持立场的。所以我回过头去重新看了，在那场戏里，吉姆正试图向迈克尔解释，
how he should slow play things with Holly. Uh-huh. And he's explaining the history of his relationship with Pam. Okay. Here is the clip from Goodby Toby Part One that Gabrielle is referring to. Let's hear it. Here, Michael, you can quarter as you get to know her, you know?
他应该如何慢慢和霍莉发展关系。嗯哼。他正在解释他与帕姆关系的历程。好的。以下是加布里埃拉提到的《告别托比》第一集的片段。我们听听看。听着，迈克尔，你可以在了解她的过程中慢慢来，你知道的？
I mean, the office is a great place for that. Pam and I, we got to know each other right out there. I mean, first time we joked around was at my desk. And the first meal we ever had was in the break room, actually. We were at two separate tables, and I remember that. First time we kissed even was right outside. And look, all I'm saying is that you can get to know someone really, really well. Like I did right here at work.
我的意思是，办公室是个好地方。我和帕姆，我们就在外面认识彼此的。我的意思是，我们第一次开玩笑是在我的办公桌旁。我们吃的第一顿饭其实是在休息室。我们当时坐在两张不同的桌子旁，我记得。甚至我们第一次接吻也是在外面。听着，我只想说你可以非常非常了解一个人。就像我在工作时在这里做到的那样。
Right here. At work. Right there, not at Chili's. No, case closed. I'm sorry, case closed. You know what? What? All right.
就在这里。在工作时。就在那里，不在奇利餐厅。不，案子结了。抱歉，案子结了。你知道吗？什么？好吧。
OK. OK. To make it official, to make it official, let's do a poll. Show of hands. Who thinks their first kiss? You have all the evidence now. I'm not right.
好吧。好吧。为了让它官方化，为了让它官方化，我们做个民意调查。举手。谁认为他们的初吻是……你们现在有了所有的证据。我没有对吧？
Oh, lights up. Lights up. Uh-huh. We're going to see how you vote. Who thinks their first kiss was casino night Who thinks it was Dundee's? Yes, there are bad roads Dundee's head out hold out I mean I have three in the back row in front row. Oh my gosh. I have multiple people here but most people
哦，灯亮了。灯亮了。嗯哼。我们要看看你们怎么投票。谁认为他们的初吻是赌场之夜？谁认为那是邓迪奖之夜？是的，后排有几个。邓迪奖之夜，坚持住。我的意思是后排有三个人，前排也有。哦，天哪。这里有很多人，但大多数人
agree with me and with logic and reason and evidence I just want to say something to you and Pastor Paul for one second. Pastor Paul, first of all, I want to come to one of your sermons because I feel like you really pill back the layers. But here's what I want to say. If we're going to have this debate and really have a true honest debate about this, then I need to know what Jim and Pam think is a kiss.
都同意我的看法，以及逻辑、理性和证据。我只想对你和保罗牧师说句话。保罗牧师，首先，我想去听一次你的布道，因为我觉得你真的剥丝抽茧、剖析得很透彻。但我想说的是：如果我们要做这场辩论，并真正进行一场真实诚实的辩论，那么我需要知道吉姆和帕姆认为什么是接吻。
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you, background. You need to define a kiss. Yeah, define a kiss because I thought to lips lock. I know, but lips can touch other lips. Excuse me. Also, by the way, it wasn't a full lip.
是的。谢谢。谢谢后排。你需要下一个接吻的定义。是的，下一个定义，因为我以为接吻是双唇紧锁。我知道，但嘴唇可以碰到别的嘴唇。打扰一下。另外，顺便说一句，那不是全唇接触。
It wasn't full lip to full lip. It was Pam pushing her lips to the side of Jim's lip. I'm going to need a screen grab. I'll get it for you. OK. And you'll see that I'm right. And Jim doesn't even pucker. That's not a kiss.
那不是嘴唇对嘴唇的饱满接触。那是帕姆把她的嘴唇凑到吉姆嘴唇的侧面。我需要一张截图。我会为你弄一张的。好的。然后你会看到我是对的。而且吉姆甚至都没有把嘴唇撅起来。那不是接吻。
That is a hug. That's not a kiss. That is not a kiss. That's not a kiss. A kiss is like, a kiss is casino night, and we all know it. And it's why our hearts melted. Fine. Yes, that was, I would say, a technical open mouth kiss. We're gonna get technical.
那是一个拥抱。那不是接吻。那不是接吻。那不是接吻。接吻就像是，接吻就是赌场之夜，我们都心知肚明。这就是为什么我们的心都融化了。好吧。是的，那可以算是一个技术意义上的微张嘴唇的吻。我们要抠技术细节了。
But lips touched, lady. Lips touched. There was lips touching. It is not a kiss. Oh my gosh. I can't believe that we have not settled this. I've never settled this. I've never changed again.
但嘴唇确实碰到了，女士。嘴唇碰到了。那不是接吻。哦，天哪。我真不敢相信我们还没解决这个问题。我从来没有解决过。我再也没有改变过立场。
I'm holding strong for Casino and I. And that is totally fine. But I will always be on the can. Thank you, Emily. I'm the can't. For bringing me back to my sister. Pastor Paul, Fabriela. All right, we can move camp. Thank you, Emily. I'm the camp. Paul, for bringing me back to my sister. Pastor Paul, sorry. I'm a reala.
我坚守赌场之夜。这完全没问题。但我将永远站在……谢谢你，艾米莉。我站在……带我回到我妹妹身边的保罗牧师，加布里埃拉。好吧，我们可以换个阵营。谢谢你，艾米莉。我站在……保罗牧师，对不起。我真的是……
All right, we can move on. Thank you to my back row and my handful of people over here. Who witnessed lips touch lips? All right. Danielle from Somerville, Massachusetts, wrote in because Jenna, she loves our deep dives. And in particular, she was very excited to hear about the Summerville's fluff festival. Okay.
好吧，我们可以继续了。谢谢我后排的观众和这里的一小撮人。谁见证了嘴唇接触嘴唇？好的。来自马萨诸塞州萨默维尔的丹妮尔写信来，因为珍娜，她喜欢我们的深入探讨。特别是，她非常高兴听到关于萨默维尔棉花糖节的事情。好的。
Because she has been there. Okay. And she even brought us t-shirts from the fluff festival. Here they are. I love this. I remember this. I had never heard of this fluffernutter. Yes, I said have you had a fluffernutter
因为她去过那里。好的。她甚至给我们带来了棉花糖节的T恤。它们在这里。我好喜欢。我记得这个。我以前从未听说过这个棉花糖三明治。是的，我说过你吃过棉花糖三明治吗？
and Jenna Snickerd, like I'd said a dirty word. I'd never heard of this thing. No, I made you a fluffernutter. Oh! Oh! What? Mm-hmm. What's on it again?
然后珍娜吃吃地笑了起来，就像我说了一个脏字一样。我以前从没听说过这东西。不，我给你做了一个棉花糖三明治。哦！哦！什么？嗯哼。里面有什么来着？
It's peanut butter and fluff, like, you know, marshmallow fluff and I got gluten-free bread. It's very tiny. It smells good. It's peanut butter and fluff. There's nothing else in it. You don't want to buy? No, I'm going to eat it.
里面是花生酱和棉花糖霜，你知道的，就是棉花糖霜，我买的是无麸质面包。它非常小。闻起来很香。里面是花生酱和棉花糖霜。里面没有别的了。你不想买？不，我要把它吃掉。
Are you nervous about it? Have you all ever had one of these? Yes. And they're good. They're delicious. OK, all right. I wanted to And they're good. They're delicious. Okay, all right. I wanted to eat it for breakfast.
你对此感到紧张吗？你们以前都吃过这个吗？是的。而且它们很好吃。它们很美味。好吧，好吧。我想把它……而且它们很好吃。它们很美味。好吧，好吧。我想把这个当早餐吃。
I almost did. I mean, my gosh. I don't want this to become another star wars, but. You don't like it! Oh my gosh. It's two sticky things. Me, no, I mean, oh, so I can barely even talk. All of the saliva has been sucked out of my mouth.
我差点就说了。我是说，天哪。我可不想让这变成另一个星球大战，但是。你不喜欢它！哦天哪。这是两个黏糊糊的东西。我，不，我是说，哦，我都说不出话来了。我嘴里的唾液全被吸干了。
This is why jelly is important. Well, because it smooths out the peanut butter. I mean, I'm still eating it, though, I don't know. It's too deep. It's too deep to keep eating it. You don't have to keep eating it, but that's a fluffernutter. Okay. I've now had a fluffernutter.
这就是果冻很重要的原因。嗯，因为它能让花生酱更顺滑。我是说，不过我还在吃，我不知道。太深了。太深了，没法一直吃下去。你不用一直吃，但那是棉花糖花生酱三明治。好吧。我现在吃过棉花糖花生酱三明治了。
I've watched NARWARDS and I've had a fluffernutter. Yay. Where will it end? All right, Angela. Okay. I have some beverages to share with you. Okay. Okay.
我看过《星球大战》我也吃过棉花糖花生酱三明治。耶。何时是个头啊？好了，安吉拉。好吧。我有一些饮料要跟你分享。好吧。好吧。
Can I have a little bit of the fluffernutter? Yeah. Here's the fluffernutters. You can have as much of it as you want. Okay. Thank you for making it. I'm glad I've tried it. This is clearly my year of doing things for the first time.
我能吃一点点那个棉花糖花生酱三明治吗？可以。棉花糖花生酱三明治在这。你想吃多少就吃多少。好的。谢谢你做的。我很高兴我尝过了。这绝对是我第一次尝试新事物的一年。
Mm, that is so good. Okay, here are some beverages. First off, Michael M. sent us Sunny Cat Beer. You know my cat's name is Sunny. It's an orange cat. He found this in St. Louis, Missouri. Look at this. In St. Louis? Sunny Cat Beer. Oh my god, that is so cute cat. He found this in St. Louis, Missouri. Look at this. In St. Louis?
嗯，太好吃了。好吧，这里有一些饮料。首先，迈克尔·M给我们寄了阳光猫啤酒。你知道我猫的名字叫阳光。它是一只橘猫。他在密苏里州圣路易斯找到了这个。看这个。在圣路易斯？阳光猫啤酒。哦天哪，那只猫太可爱了。他在密苏里州圣路易斯找到了这个。看这个。在圣路易斯？
Sunny cat beer. Oh my god, that is so cute. Yeah, I read about it. They had a cat who passed away. And this is an honor of their cat, Sunshine. Sunny cat beer is a New England style pale ale with tangerine peels. Oh.
阳光猫啤酒。哦天哪，太可爱了。是的，我读过关于它的报道。他们有一只过世的猫。这是为了纪念他们的猫，阳光。阳光猫啤酒是一款新英格兰风格的淡色艾尔啤酒，带有橘子皮。哦。
Right, so there's that. Fancy beer. And then also get this, Carrie M. Centus, Cafe Disco beer. Oh, also get this, Carrie M. sent us Cafe Disco beer. Oh, so cute! Let me see. That is so fun. It's from the Stelwagen brewery in Massachusetts.
好，就是这样。精酿啤酒。然后还有这个，凯莉·M送我们的“咖啡迪斯科”啤酒。哦，还有这个，凯莉·M送我们的“咖啡迪斯科”啤酒。哦，太可爱了！我看看。太有趣了。这是马萨诸塞州的斯特尔瓦根酿酒厂生产的。
Well, we need to send a picture to Warren Hall said. They wrote that episode. It's like cute. All right, I'm a sucker for packaging. Carrie M. did say maybe don't drink that beer because it might be really old. Carrie had a hard time finding our address. So oh no you are not going to drink it. I was that person in college guys.
嗯，我们需要给沃伦·霍尔发张照片。他们写了那一集。感觉很可爱。好吧，我经不起精美包装的诱惑。凯莉·M确实说过也许别喝那瓶啤酒，因为它可能放了很久了。凯莉费了好大劲才找到我们的地址。所以，哦不，你可别喝它。我上大学时就是那种人，伙计们。
It's stout. I don't hate it though. Okay, well here's Sunny Cat beer. Do you want to try a sunny beer? Sure. Okay, it's real foamy. It's real foamy. What's the thing where you do the grease off your nose and put it on the foam? Have you guys ever heard of that? I'm showing my true colors. I can't, this, this, what, you know, it kind of reminds me of like a Guinness. I don't mind, I don't mind Cafe Disco. I think it's turned. No, it hasn't turned. That's tangy.
这是烈性黑啤酒。不过我倒不讨厌。好吧，这是阳光猫啤酒。你想尝尝阳光啤酒吗？当然。好吧，泡沫真多。泡沫真多。你听说过用鼻子上的油擦在泡沫上的那种事吗？你们听说过吗？我露出马脚了。我不能，这个，这个，什么，你知道，它有点让我想起吉尼斯啤酒。我不介意，我不介意“咖啡迪斯科”。我觉得它变质了。不，没变质。那是酸甜的。
I don't mind Sunny Cat. You'll like it better. This just tastes like a gum. Oh yeah, this Sunny Cat beer has like, I taste the mind Sunny Cat. You'll like it better. This just tastes like a goat. Oh yeah, the Sunny Cat beer has like, I taste the tangerine. I do. Mm, that's a good beer. Well, thank you very much.
我不介意阳光猫啤酒。你会更喜欢它的。这个尝起来就像口香糖。哦对，这个阳光猫啤酒有，我尝到了阳光猫。你会更喜欢它的。这个尝起来像山羊。哦对，阳光猫啤酒有，我尝到了橘子味。确实有。嗯，这是款好啤酒。非常感谢。
You're welcome. I did not get beer, but I have a great coffee hookup for us all. Mary Telly, the founder and CEO of the Electric City Roasting Company, sent all of us bags of boom-roasted coffee. Woohoo! Yes! And? Yes!
不客气。我没带啤酒，但我为我们大家找到了一个很好的咖啡供应商。玛丽·泰利，电城烘焙公司的创始人兼首席执行官，给我们所有人寄来了几袋轰动烘焙咖啡。哇哦！耶！还有？是的！
Well, you remember because I did a deep dive. It all started when I was deep diving Andy's mug from the seminar. And then that led me to the Zumos Cafe, which then led me to the Electric City Roasting Company. I got a letter from Anna S, who heard that episode, who lives in Scranton. Anna went to Zumos Cafe. Anna sent us both mugs from Zumos!
嗯，你还记得，因为我做了一番深入研究。这一切都始于我深入研究安迪在研讨会上的马克杯。然后这引导我找到了祖莫斯咖啡馆，接着又引导我找到了电城烘焙公司。我收到了一封来自安娜·S的信，她听了那一集，住在斯克兰顿。安娜去了祖莫斯咖啡馆。安娜给我们俩都寄了祖莫斯马克杯！
Oh, I love it! I know! We heart-scratt-n. Mm-hmm. Well, speaking of all of this food and beverages, I think we should wrap this up because we have a little party plan for everyone that came today. You know I love a party. I was the head of the PPC and in real life I am. And we have a really fun reception plan with food and beverages and little gift bags.
哦，我太喜欢了！我知道！我们爱斯克兰顿。嗯。说到所有的这些食物和饮料，我觉得我们该收尾了，因为我们为今天来的每个人准备了一个小型派对。你知道我喜欢派对。我是派对策划委员会的负责人，现实生活中我也是。我们策划了一个非常有趣的招待会，有食物和饮料，还有小礼品袋。
Yes, we have nifty gifties for everyone. Everyone here is going to get an office lady's book bag filled with goodies. There's really fun stuff in there including the boom roasted coffee and more from some really wonderful companies that contributed to the bag. Yeah, you're going to get a backpack full of stuff. Yes. And so we just want to say thank you so much for listening out there. Thanks for sending in your letters. Thank you to the entire staff who put together this live recording.
是的，我们为每个人准备了精美小礼品。这里的每个人都会得到一个装满好东西的办公室女郎书包。里面有非常有趣的东西，包括轰动烘焙咖啡以及赞助该礼品袋的一些非常棒的公司的其他产品。是的，你们会得到一个装满东西的双肩包。是的。所以我们只想对外面收听的各位说非常感谢。谢谢你们寄来信件。感谢为这次现场录音付出努力的全体员工。
Yeah, of our podcast. Yes. And just thank you guys so much for being here today. We know you traveled from far places and you made a trip out of it. And it just means so much for being here today. We know you traveled from far places and you made a trip out of it and it just means so much to us and you have been part of our journey for so long and let's go have a little party together.
是的，我们的播客。是的。非常感谢大家今天能来到这里。我们知道你们是从很远的地方赶来的，特意跑了一趟。这真的对我们意义重大，你们陪伴我们的旅程这么久了，让我们一起去开个小型派对吧。
My party! Yay! Yay! Yay! That's great! That's great! Yay! Woo!
我的派对！耶！耶！耶！太棒了！太棒了！耶！呜！
Yay! Yay! Woo! Yay! Yay! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Well there you have it, our first live episode of Office Ladies. It was so special.
耶！耶！呜！耶！耶！感谢收听《办公室女郎》。《办公室女郎》由 Earwolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是里德·勃拉顿的《橡胶树》。好了，这就是我们的第一期《办公室女郎》现场播客。太特别了。
The energy in that room, it was so positive and it was so fun. I loved it. I loved it. I loved getting to meet everyone. I loved our little reception party afterwards. And I want to do another one. I'd be up for that. And we also want to say a big thank you to Hershey's Kisses
那个房间里的能量，太积极了，太有趣了。我很喜欢。我太喜欢了。我很喜欢认识大家。我很喜欢我们随后的招待派对。我还想再办一次。我完全赞成。我们还要非常感谢好时之吻
for sponsoring this special episode. With Hershey's Kisses' chocolates, you and your family can unwrap presents all month long, making little moments together feel special. These little candies pack a big chocolate taste. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
赞助这一特殊单集。有了好时之吻巧克力，你和家人可以一整个月都在拆礼物，让在一起的每个小时刻都感觉很特别。这些小糖果蕴含着浓郁的巧克力风味。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。